programming throwdown episode 160 position localization take it away patrick welcome to a nice uh ending in zero episodes it's like a yeah 10th thing 160 16 10s we've had it's our sweet 16 sweet deca 16 i guess oh i was trying to come up thank you that was better so i want to talk about something that i feel was always loitered around i remember it going back a little bit of a nostalgia trip, and then we're going to take it forward. So I'm going to give why I'm bringing it up, and then I'll sort of get into my monologue here. But I remember going back to,
programming throwdown episode 160 position localization take it away patrick welcome to a nice uh ending in zero episodes it's like a yeah 10th thing 160 16 10s we've had it's our sweet 16 sweet deca 16 i guess oh i was trying to come up thank you that was better so i want to talk about something that i feel was always loitered around i remember it going back a little bit of a nostalgia trip, and then we're going to take it forward. So I'm going to give why I'm bringing it up, and then I'll sort of get into my monologue here. But I remember going back to,|||编程脱口秀第 160 期，关于定位，帕特里克，你来吧。欢迎来到一个以零结尾的节目，这就像是一个第 10 个东西，160、16 个 10，我们经历过，这是我们的甜蜜 16，甜蜜十进制 16，我想，哦，我想想看，谢谢，那样更好。所以我想谈谈一件我感觉一直在周围徘徊的事情，我记得这有点像一次怀旧之旅，然后我们要把它推进。所以我要讲讲我为什么要提起这件事，然后我就会进入我的独白。但我记得回到，
okay, not all the way when I was a kid, that's too far. But I remember going back to like the early 2000s, and there being portable PCs. So not like a laptop. I mean, that's kind of been a thing. Like it's kind of obvious, but I'm talking about something in sort of like, okay, like a Game Boy Advance, Nintendo DS, that form factor. And the reason I'm bringing this up is the Steam Deck. So the Steam Deck is
okay, not all the way when I was a kid, that's too far. But I remember going back to like the early 2000s, and there being portable PCs. So not like a laptop. I mean, that's kind of been a thing. Like it's kind of obvious, but I'm talking about something in sort of like, okay, like a Game Boy Advance, Nintendo DS, that form factor. And the reason I'm bringing this up is the Steam Deck. So the Steam Deck is|||好吧，也不是一直回到我小时候，那太远了。但我记得回到 2000 年代初期，当时有便携式电脑。所以不是像笔记本电脑那样。我的意思是，那已经是一种东西了。就像这有点显而易见，但我在谈论一种类似于，好吧，像 Game Boy Advance、Nintendo DS 那种外形的产品。我提起这个的原因是 Steam Deck。所以 Steam Deck 现在
now sort of generally available. Just recently, it's been like, I think they're going to be in retail shops in Japan, I saw some cool pictures. And so instead of this hyped up, you know, hard to get big waiting lists, you have to pay over asking the Steam Deck has come out. And I want to talk about so I have one, I hadn't played it a lot. But now I've been playing it more and more. And I'm going to sort of talk about like my journey, but also this nostalgia trip of I remember there used to be Sony stores, Sony retail stores, and there was a specific mall, you know, I was older, but you know, we were in this must have i didn't look at my show looked it up like 2001 2002 2003 that time frame and you would go to the sony store and they would have you know the digital cameras
now sort of generally available. Just recently, it's been like, I think they're going to be in retail shops in Japan, I saw some cool pictures. And so instead of this hyped up, you know, hard to get big waiting lists, you have to pay over asking the Steam Deck has come out. And I want to talk about so I have one, I hadn't played it a lot. But now I've been playing it more and more. And I'm going to sort of talk about like my journey, but also this nostalgia trip of I remember there used to be Sony stores, Sony retail stores, and there was a specific mall, you know, I was older, but you know, we were in this must have i didn't look at my show looked it up like 2001 2002 2003 that time frame and you would go to the sony store and they would have you know the digital cameras|||可以说是全面上市了。就在最近，好像，我看到一些很酷的照片，它们似乎要在日本的零售店上架了。所以，不再是那种被炒作得很高、很难买到、有很长的等待名单、你不得不支付高于标价的 Steam Deck 了。我想谈谈——我有一个，我以前没怎么玩过。但现在我玩得越来越多了。我要谈谈我的心路历程，还有这次怀旧之旅，我记得以前有索尼专卖店、索尼零售店，有一个特定的商场，你知道，我当时年龄大一点，但你知道，我们在那个时间段——我没看我的节目，查了一下大概是 2001、2002、2003 年那个时间段——你会去索尼专卖店，那里有数码相机，
they would have these little like bio computers that had like little tiny keyboards and like a screen and i never knew that you know before the iphone right before sort of on-screen capacitive sensing this is like resistive touch they didn't have a long life there wasn't you know data oversell networks wasn't like an everyday person thing and so they just weren't all that compelling maybe if you had like a very specific use case you know you would have done it but for most folks it wasn't super compelling and i feel like you know they've kind of ran windows maybe you could get one that run linux if you were an elite hacker or had some specific thing but you like they kind of ran Windows. Maybe you could get one that ran Linux if you were an elite hacker or had some specific thing. But they kind of languished around.
they would have these little like bio computers that had like little tiny keyboards and like a screen and i never knew that you know before the iphone right before sort of on-screen capacitive sensing this is like resistive touch they didn't have a long life there wasn't you know data oversell networks wasn't like an everyday person thing and so they just weren't all that compelling maybe if you had like a very specific use case you know you would have done it but for most folks it wasn't super compelling and i feel like you know they've kind of ran windows maybe you could get one that run linux if you were an elite hacker or had some specific thing but you like they kind of ran Windows. Maybe you could get one that run Linux if you were an elite hacker or had some specific thing. But they kind of languished around.|||它们会有那种带有微型键盘和屏幕的小型 VAIO 电脑，我从来不知道，你知道，在 iPhone 出现之前，也就是屏幕电容触控出现之前，这就像是电阻式触控，它们的寿命不长，也没有什么数据泛滥的网络，不是普通人的日常用品，所以它们并没有那么吸引人，也许如果你有一个非常具体的使用场景，你知道，你可能会买，但对大多数人来说，它们并不是超级吸引人，我觉得，你知道，它们运行的基本上是 Windows，也许如果你是一个精英黑客或者有什么特殊需求，你可以买到运行 Linux 的版本，但你喜欢……它们基本上运行的是 Windows。也许如果你是一个精英黑客或有什么特殊需求，你可以买到运行 Linux 的版本。但它们一直在那里半死不活地徘徊。
And then the Steam Deck, for some reason, captured my excitement. Maybe in part, it's just I have this belief that I'm going to be a video gamer, even though I'm not really a video gamer. I'm just a casual gamer. I play just iOS games or whatever. I'm not big on PC games. I hardly ever sit at my computer and play them. I do have one. It is not technically a gaming PC pc but i just have a gpu it is capable i just don't sit there and play it very often but i got the steam deck and i already had a bunch of games
And then the Steam Deck, for some reason, captured my excitement. Maybe in part, it's just I have this belief that I'm going to be a video gamer, even though I'm not really a video gamer. I'm just a casual gamer. I play just iOS games or whatever. I'm not big on PC games. I hardly ever sit at my computer and play them. I do have one. It is not technically a gaming PC pc but i just have a gpu it is capable i just don't sit there and play it very often but i got the steam deck and i already had a bunch of games|||然后，Steam Deck 不知何故点燃了我的热情。也许部分原因只是我有一种信念，觉得自己会成为一个电子游戏玩家，尽管我并不是真正的游戏玩家。我只是一个休闲玩家。我只玩 iOS 游戏或诸如此类的东西。我不大玩 PC 游戏。我几乎从不坐在电脑前玩游戏。我确实有一台电脑。它在技术上不是一台游戏 PC，但我有一张 GPU，它能胜任，我只是不经常坐在那里玩，但我买了 Steam Deck，而且我本来就有很多游戏，
huge appeal to me that you know you can have lots of concerns about drm or whatever i'm just going to leave that aside for this conversation but through various humble bundles and other things i picked up lots of you know five to ten year old video games, which was like perfect for the Steam Deck. So can the Steam Deck play anything? Like what's the connection between Steam and the Steam Deck? So this is the part that's really cool. So first, it already comes built in with access to your Steam library. Okay.
huge appeal to me that you know you can have lots of concerns about drm or whatever i'm just going to leave that aside for this conversation but through various humble bundles and other things i picked up lots of you know five to ten year old video games, which was like perfect for the Steam Deck. So can the Steam Deck play anything? Like what's the connection between Steam and the Steam Deck? So this is the part that's really cool. So first, it already comes built in with access to your Steam library. Okay.|||对我有着巨大的吸引力，你知道，你可以对 DRM 或其他东西有很多担忧，我在这段对话中先把它放一边，但通过各种 Humble Bundle 和其他渠道，我收集了许多你知道的五到十年前的电子游戏，这简直是为 Steam Deck 量身定做的。那么 Steam Deck 什么都能玩吗？Steam 和 Steam Deck 之间有什么联系？这正是最酷的部分。首先，它内置了对你的 Steam 游戏库的访问权限。好吧。
The second thing is the way they've made it is, you know, to a lot of cell phones it's it's very commodity parts so it's a x86 processor from amd with an integrated gpu and by default it runs on steam os which is built on top of linux but it very easily will let you drop back into linux you can attach a keyboard and mouse and like install your own packages wow but you could also install windows you can dual boot i haven't that. It's a little off the beaten path, because they're still working BIOS changes and stuff to build it. One day, I think I'll do that. For now, I'm not. So what they've done is they have this library called Proton. And Proton, I'm pretty sure this is great. Proton is sort of like what Wine did, right? Like providing the Windows API calls and doing a translation under the hood. So all of
The second thing is the way they've made it is, you know, to a lot of cell phones it's it's very commodity parts so it's a x86 processor from amd with an integrated gpu and by default it runs on steam os which is built on top of linux but it very easily will let you drop back into linux you can attach a keyboard and mouse and like install your own packages wow but you could also install windows you can dual boot i haven't that. It's a little off the beaten path, because they're still working BIOS changes and stuff to build it. One day, I think I'll do that. For now, I'm not. So what they've done is they have this library called Proton. And Proton, I'm pretty sure this is great. Proton is sort of like what Wine did, right? Like providing the Windows API calls and doing a translation under the hood. So all of|||第二点是他们的制造方式，你知道，对许多手机来说，它采用的是非常通用的零件，所以它是一个来自 AMD 的 x86 处理器，带有集成 GPU，默认运行在建立在 Linux 之上的 Steam OS 上，但它可以非常轻松地让你退回 Linux 环境，你可以连接键盘和鼠标，就像安装你自己的软件包一样，哇，但你也可以安装 Windows，你可以双系统启动，我还没这样做。这有点非主流，因为他们仍在努力进行 BIOS 更改等来构建它。总有一天，我想我会这么做的。目前我还没做。所以他们做的是，他们有一个叫 Proton 的库。而且 Proton，我很确定这太棒了。Proton 有点像 Wine 做的事情，对吧？比如提供 Windows API 调用并在底层进行转换。所以所有这些
these developers have built all of these games, but most of them don't run on Linux sort of natively. They run on x86, but they make Windows or DirectX calls or whatever, and it can cause issues. And so there's this interface wrapper that they will run and detect it. And they also provide this mapping from the keys and they have trackpads. They've done some cool stuff on the hardware but on the software side yeah it's super compelling and so all these games just sort of like they have ones that they verified work which is a huge lift on their part that they're like trying to go through and figure out ones that work and there are quite a surprising number that work fully like they understand the steam deck they don't pop up an on-screen keyboard that
these developers have built all of these games, but most of them don't run on Linux sort of natively. They run on x86, but they make Windows or DirectX calls or whatever, and it can cause issues. And so there's this interface wrapper that they will run and detect it. And they also provide this mapping from the keys and they have trackpads. They've done some cool stuff on the hardware but on the software side yeah it's super compelling and so all these games just sort of like they have ones that they verified work, which is a huge lift on their part that they're like trying to go through and figure out ones that work and there are quite a surprising number that work fully like they understand the steam deck they don't pop up an on-screen keyboard that|||开发者都构建了所有这些游戏，但其中大多数在 Linux 上并不是原生运行的。它们运行在 x86 上，但它们会发出 Windows 或 DirectX 调用之类的指令，这可能会导致问题。因此有一个他们会运行并检测它的接口包装器。他们还提供了按键映射，并且有触控板。他们在硬件上做了一些很酷的事情，但在软件方面，是的，它超级引人入胜，所以所有这些游戏，就好像他们有验证过能运行的游戏，这对他们来说是一项巨大的工作，他们试图去浏览并找出能运行的游戏，而且有相当惊人数量的游戏可以完全运行，就像它们了解 Steam Deck 一样，它们不会弹出屏幕键盘，
you need to type like they recognize like you can use your game pad to sort of enter audit and because now there's a lot of cross play with playstation and you know xbox and pc a lot of developers have these kinds of things in mind when they're building the games but it's just really coming to its own and for me what what i was trying initially was a few games like dice and sphere program i was really into that a few games like dice and sphere program i was really into that at the time like i'm gonna play this on my steam it was terrible i hated it it was not good i just needed a mouse and keyboard people use the trackpad they have actually a community that owns like all these different customizations so you can just go to
you need to type like they recognize like you can use your game pad to sort of enter audit and because now there's a lot of cross play with playstation and you know xbox and pc a lot of developers have these kinds of things in mind when they're building the games but it's just really coming to its own and for me what what i was trying initially was a few games like dice and sphere program i was really into that a few games like dice and sphere program i was really into that at the time like i'm gonna play this on my steam it was terrible i hated it it was not good i just needed a mouse and keyboard people use the trackpad they have actually a community that owns like all these different customizations so you can just go to|||你需要输入的那种，它们能识别，比如你可以用游戏手柄来输入……而且因为现在 PlayStation、Xbox 和 PC 之间有很多跨平台联机，许多开发者在制作游戏时都会考虑到这些事情，但它确实迎来了属于自己的时代，对我和我最初尝试的一些游戏来说，比如戴森球计划，我当时真的很喜欢戴森球计划，当时我想：我要在我的 Steam 上玩这个，结果太糟糕了，我讨厌它，一点也不好，我需要鼠标和键盘，人们使用触控板，实际上有一个社区拥有所有这些不同的定制，所以你只需前往
the library and people have like reviewed key mappings where like different spots on the like little touch pads on the side correspond to different things. And hardcore users are probably hating me because there's an amazing in-depth like customization group who probably spend as much time like optimizing settings and like running plugins to sort of manipulate like under the hood things. I'm not that person. They're just like install a game and try it. That's very satisfying for those people, you but it's it's a whole like dedicated hobby to do yeah yeah like it becomes as much of a hobby as playing the game right and some newer games like elden ring and stuff supposedly run really well i'm too cheap to buy it so like i
the library and people have like reviewed key mappings where like different spots on the like little touch pads on the side correspond to different things. And hardcore users are probably hating me because there's an amazing in-depth like customization group who probably spend as much time like optimizing settings and like running plugins to sort of manipulate like under the hood things. I'm not that person. They're just like install a game and try it. That's very satisfying for those people, you but it's it's a whole like dedicated hobby to do yeah yeah like it's as much of a hobby as playing the game right and some newer games like elden ring and stuff supposedly run really well i'm too cheap to buy it so like i|||资料库，人们会审查按键映射，侧面小触控板上的不同位置对应不同的功能。硬核用户可能在恨我，因为有一个令人惊叹的深度定制小组，他们可能花同样多的时间来优化设置和运行插件来操纵底层的东西。我不是那种人。他们只是安装一个游戏并尝试一下。对那些人来说，这非常满足，但这是一项专门的爱好，是的，是的，这就和玩游戏本身一样成为了一种爱好，对吧，而且一些较新的游戏，比如《艾尔登法环》等，据说运行得非常好，我太抠门了舍不得买，所以像我
don't actually own it's too new but it's like but it's like 10 bucks i'll buy it and i've got a big backlog but what i realized was embracing sort of more casual games that I had just never played before so like everyone raves about Hades I'd had it on oh it's a great one my Xbox but like on the Steam it just works great because you it's it's sort of like a short run time sit and play but it's not something I have some of those on my phone that or my iPad that I'll try to play like dead cells but. But just like for me, having the game pad and like, it was just a much better experience. How do you carry the Steam Deck? Like it doesn't fit in your pocket, right?
don't actually own it's too new but it's like but it's like 10 bucks i'll buy it and i've got a big backlog but what i realized was embracing sort of more casual games that I had just never played before so like everyone raves about Hades I'd had it on oh it's a great one my Xbox but like on the Steam it just works great because you it's it's sort of like a short run time sit and play but it's not something I have some of those on my phone that or my iPad that I'll try to play like dead cells but. But just like for me, having the game pad and like, it was just a much better experience. How do you carry the Steam Deck? Like it doesn't fit in your pocket, right?|||其实并没有买，它太新了，但如果只要 10 块钱我就会买，而且我积压了很多游戏没玩，但我意识到的是，去拥抱那些我以前从未玩过的更休闲的游戏，比如每个人都在赞美《哈迪斯》，我曾在我的 Xbox 上玩过——哦，这是一部杰作，但在 Steam 上它运行得非常棒，因为它的单局游戏时间较短，坐下来就能玩，但这不是那种我在手机或 iPad 上会尝试玩的——比如《细胞迷途》之类的。但对我来说，拥有游戏手柄，这种体验要好得多。你平时怎么携带 Steam Deck？它装不进你的口袋，对吧？
So this is the kind of thing you need like a backpack. You have very big pockets. You have those old JNCO jeans from like the 90s. Cargo pants. So one of the things, they have a really nice carrying case that comes with it, but you're right, it's sort of bulky. So now though that,
So this is the kind of thing you need like a backpack. You have very big pockets. You have those old JNCO jeans from like the 90s. Cargo pants. So one of the things, they have a really nice carrying case that comes with it, but you're right, it's sort of bulky. So now though that,|||所以这是那种你需要背包的东西。除非你有很大的口袋。你有那种 90 年代的老式 JNCO 牛仔裤。工装裤。所以其中一点是，它自带一个非常不错的便携包，但你说的对，它有点笨重。不过现在，
because there's enough of them have been moved and the community is sort of building up around it you can actually get a variety of companies are making at different price points sort of silicone like wrapper things that go around the outside like rubberized uh stuff that have like hatches over the top to protect your screen so it won't survive like a drop in your backpack but if you want to just slide it in and not have your screen get scratched you can put a scratch protector they also have little domes that cover the control sticks so they don't get you know knocked um so i recently go and they have like little kickstand on the back so you can have a controller and like kickstand it up like on an airplane or something so there's a lot of these things building up and then i recently there's you know been a lot of hype so the switch is kind of nintendo switch is like in a similar form factor i think that's been a great you know
because there's enough of them have been moved and the community is sort of building up around it you can actually get a variety of companies are making at different price points sort of like wrapper things that go around the outside like rubberized uh stuff that have like hatches over the top to protect your screen so it won't survive like a drop in your backpack but if you want to just slide it in and not have your screen get scratched you can put a scratch protector they also have little domes that cover the control sticks so they don't get you know knocked um so i recently go and they have like little kickstand on the back so you can have a controller and like kickstand it up like on an airplane or something so there's a lot of these things building up and then i recently there's you know been a lot of hype so the switch is kind of nintendo switch is like in a similar form factor i think that's been a great you know|||由于已经售出了足够多的数量，并且围绕它的社区也在建立起来，你实际上可以买到各种各样不同价格的公司生产的外壳套件，就像包在外面的一样，比如橡胶材质的东西，顶部有盖子来保护你的屏幕，虽然它经不起在背包里掉落的摔打，但如果你只是想把它塞进去而不让屏幕被刮伤，你可以贴一个防刮膜，它们还有覆盖控制摇杆的小穹顶，这样它们就不会被撞坏，嗯，所以我最近去看了看，它们背面还有小支架，这样你就可以连接手柄，然后把它支起来，比如在飞机上或什么地方，所以有很多这样的小配件涌现出来，然后我最近，你知道的，有很多炒作，所以 Switch 类似于 Nintendo Switch 的外形尺寸，我认为这是一个很棒的，你知道的
kind of cool thing that it's both the like successor to the game boy and nintendo ds kind of lines but also with the console from nintendo that's pretty cool in the same vein in my opinion it's almost similar hardware but and now there's some new ones coming out as well from other companies and what i just wanted to shout out is like, I think it's kind of here, like the sort of miniaturized computer, it can't have a web browser, plays all these games and is much more just yours than sort of the phone ecosystem. And they're going to kind of shrink. And then coming from the other end, there's a bunch of big phones put into the same sort
kind of cool thing that it's both the like successor to the game boy and nintendo ds kind of lines but also with the console from nintendo that's pretty cool in the same vein in my opinion it's almost similar hardware but and now there's some new ones coming out as well from other companies and what i just wanted to shout out is like, I think it's kind of here, like the sort of miniaturized computer, it can't have a web browser, plays all these games and is much more just yours than sort of the phone ecosystem. And they're going to kind of shrink. And then coming from the other end, there's a bunch of big phones put into the same sort|||很酷的事情，它既是 Game Boy 和 Nintendo DS 系列的继承者，又带有任天堂的游戏主机血统，这真的很酷，在某种程度上，在我看来，它几乎是相似的硬件，但现在其他公司也有一些新产品问世，而我只想大声疾呼的是，我认为它差不多已经普及了，就像这种微型化电脑，它可以有网页浏览器，能玩所有这些游戏，而且比手机生态系统更完全属于你。它们将会不断缩小。然后从另一端来看，有一堆大屏手机被塞进同一种
of form factor, but a little bit smaller where they look like Game Boy Advances or whatever. And they're really just running Android emulators and you can play retro games, but also Android games. So dead cells and things work great. And so they're sort of converging into this like middle ground of sizing that you can just play really, really powerful
form factor, but a little bit smaller where they look like Game Boy Advances or whatever. And they're really just running Android emulators and you can play retro games, but also Android games. So dead cells and things work great. And so they're sort of converging into this like middle ground of sizing that you can just play really, really powerful|||外形中，但要小一些，它们看起来像 Game Boy Advance 之类的东西。它们实际上只是在运行 Android 模拟器，你可以玩复古游戏，也可以玩 Android 游戏。所以《细胞迷途》之类的游戏运行效果很好。因此，它们正在收敛到这种中间尺寸，让你可以畅玩非常非常强大的
sort of like games and have this sort of on the go experience. I just think it's really cool. Yeah, I used to have back when slider phones were a big deal where you'd slide the keyboard, you know, from under the phone. I used to have a phone. I don't remember what it's called. It's called a I don't remember, but it was from Sony.
sort of like games and have this sort of on the go experience. I just think it's really cool. Yeah, I used to have back when slider phones were a big deal where you'd slide the keyboard, you know, from under the phone. I used to have a phone. I don't remember what it's called. It's called a I don't remember, but it was from Sony.|||游戏，并获得这种随身携带的体验。我只是觉得这真的很酷.是的，我以前在滑盖手机大行其道的时代，也就是你会把键盘，你知道的，从手机下方滑出来的那个时期。我曾有一部手机。我不记得它叫什么了。它叫——我不记得了，但它是索尼出的。
And when you slid it, it was a gamepad. And so you had like a full gamepad. It was a, you know, Android, you know, one or something very old, but that was amazing. I mean, I beat Final Fantasy seven on that. I mean, put like a ton of hours into it. Eventually, like all the slider phones, the ribbon connecting the two halves like fault, you know, fails. But yeah, that was that was phenomenal. The other thing that I was following for a long time, which sounds like the steam deck finally sort of cracked this walnut but i was following open pandora which was a uh uh basically it sounds exactly like the steam deck it ran linux you know it just the thing is it was expensive and there were just always issues with
And when you slid it, it was a gamepad. And so you had like a full gamepad. It was a, you know, Android, you know, one or something very old, but that was amazing. I mean, beat Final Fantasy seven on that. I mean, put like a ton of hours into it. Eventually, like all the slider phones, the ribbon connecting the two halves like fault, you know, fails. But yeah, that was that was phenomenal. The other thing that I was following for a long time, which sounds like the steam deck finally sort of cracked this walnut but i was following open pandora which was a uh uh basically it sounds exactly like the steam deck it ran linux you know it just the thing is it was expensive and there were just always issues with|||当你滑开它时，它就是一个游戏手柄。所以你拥有了一个完整的游戏手柄。它是一个，你知道的，Android，非常古老的版本之类的，但那太棒了。我的意思是，我在上面通关了《最终幻想 7》。我的意思是，在上面投入了大量的时间。最后，就像所有滑盖手机一样，连接两半的排线出故障了，你知道的，坏了。但是，是的，那真是太了不另外一件我关注了很久的事情，听起来 Steam Deck 终于把这块硬骨头啃下来了，但我以前一直在关注 OpenPandora，它是一个……基本上听起来和 Steam Deck 完全一样，它运行 Linux，你知道的，问题在于它很贵，而且总是存在各种
it and it just didn't have the level of polish for me to to dive in it sounds like the steam decks really got it i think for me like in part it's not trying to be everything to everyone is not trying to say oh this is going to be your laptop on the go because people just have their phones like yeah that wasn't that's not a need anymore but some people just don't want to have a gaming pc and i know folks that are like yeah i have a video game but like i i don't like what would i might spend that amount of money on a pc now go to the pc master race subreddit if you want and like you know you know indulge in your superiority but there's a lot of folks who just aren't going to do that and this is sort of like uh i think a good
it and it just didn't have the level of polish for me to to dive in it sounds like the steam decks really got it i think for me like in part it's not trying to be everything to everyone is not trying to say oh this is going to be your laptop on the go because people just have their phones like yeah that wasn't that's not a need anymore but some people just don't want to have a gaming pc and i know folks that are like yeah i have a video game but like i i don't like what would i might spend that amount of money on a pc now go to the pc master race subreddit if you want and like you know you know indulge in your superiority but there's a lot of folks who just aren't going to do that and this is sort of like uh i think a good|||问题，它的打磨程度还不足以让我投入其中，听起来 Steam Deck 真的做到了这一点。我认为对我和部分人来说，它并没有试图成为所有人的万能设备，也没有试图说“哦，这将是你出门在外的笔记本电脑”，因为人们都有手机，就像——是的，那不再是一种需求了，但有些人就是不想拥有一台游戏 PC，我认识一些人，他们会说“是的，我有一台电子游戏机，但是——我不喜欢，我现在怎么可能会花那么多钱买一台 PC 呢”，如果你愿意，可以去 PC master race 子版块，然后，你知道的，沉浸在你的优越感中，但有很多人就是不会那样做，而这有点像——我认为这是一个好的
middle ground right like you don't necessarily take it on the go like you know if you're just going to have a few minutes but you could take it on a trip with you um but you could also just play it on the couch or whatever i know i think it think it's, it's a pretty cool middle ground. And the sort of software stack that they're figuring out is really cool. Like all these Windows games being able to run on Linux. I think that's, that's really awesome. Yeah, that is super, super cool. I'll have to check this out. It looks like it's around 600 bucks, five to 700, depending on the amount of storage you want. And the great thing is like, it has really good support for the micro sd card so i bought the smallest one and i i i isn't it isn't a problem for me i just put a really big
middle ground right like you don't necessarily take it on the go like you know if you're just going to have a few minutes but you could take it on a trip with you um but you could also just play it on the couch or whatever i know i think it think it's, it's a pretty cool middle ground. And the sort of software stack that they're figuring out is really cool. Like all these Windows games being able to run on Linux. I think that's, that's really awesome. Yeah, that is super, super cool. I'll have to check this out. It looks like it's around 600 bucks, five to 700, depending on the amount of storage you want. And the great thing is like, it has really good support for the micro sd card so i bought the smallest one and i i i isn't it isn't a problem for me i just put a really big|||折中方案，对吧，比如你不一定非要在出门只有几分钟的时候带着它，但你可以在旅行时把它带上，嗯，但你也可以直接在沙发上玩它之类的一我知道，我认为这是一个相当酷的折中方案。而且他们正在弄清楚的软件栈真的很酷。比如所有这些 Windows 游戏都能够在 Linux 上运行。我认为这真的很棒。是的，这超级超级酷。我得去看看这个。看起来价格在 600 美元左右，500 到 700 美元不等，具体取决于你想要的存储容量。最棒的是，它对 micro SD 卡的支持非常好，所以我买了最小容量的那款，对我来说这不是问题，我只需要插上一张非常大的
micro sd card oh that is cool although not cheap is also like i could take it to something else if i needed to or i stopped using it it's a less of a commitment so yep that makes sense all right very cool time for the news well i did not prepare the ordering very well so i'm the first up no go for it all right so i know jason is somewhat of a retro video game enthusiast so i'm sure he's seen this person before there's a youtuber called summoning salt who just makes the most like straightforward if i tell tell you what it's about you're gonna be like whatever i'm not that like this sounds so boring which is just like in-depth exploration like an hour-long video of how the timed speed running records of various video
micro sd card oh that is cool although not cheap is also like i could take it to something else if i needed to or i stopped using it it's a less of a commitment so yep that makes sense all right very cool time for the news well i did not prepare the ordering very well so i'm the first up no go for it all right so i know jason is somewhat of a retro video game enthusiast so i'm sure he's seen this person before there's a youtuber called summoning salt who just makes the most like straightforward if i tell tell you what it's about you're gonna be like whatever i'm not that like this sounds so boring which is just like in-depth exploration like an hour-long video of how the timed speed running records of various video|||micro SD 卡，哦，这太酷了，虽然不便宜，但这也意味着如果需要的话，我可以把它用在其他地方，或者如果我不用了，这算是一个较小的投入，所以，是的，这说得通。好的，非常酷，到新闻时间了。嗯，我没有把顺序准备好，所以我先来？不，你来吧。好的，我知道杰森有点像个复古电子游戏爱好者，所以我确信他以前见过这个人。有一个叫 Summoning Salt 的 YouTuber，他制作的视频非常直白，如果我告诉你它的内容是什么，你大概会觉得“随便吧，我才不关心，听起来好无聊”，它其实就是深入探讨——一个长达一小时的视频，讲述各种电子游戏的限时速通记录是如何
games fall over time yep this guy's amazing so he gives her a narrative history he does all this work i was watching the one about super mario brothers 300 so there's like all these different categories i know nothing about this i don't have any desire to do this speed running i'll cover this okay so go for it go for it in speed running there's any percent there's 100 and then there's another one i forgot the name of it it's effectively zero percent so so any percent means you just have to get to the title, the ending screen, right? Um, a hundred percent means there's a list of things you have to do, which, which they can constitute a hundred percent of the game and it's defined in advance and you have to get to the
games fall over time yep this guy's amazing so he gives her a narrative history he does all this work i was watching the one about super mario brothers 300 so there's like all these different categories i know nothing about this i don't have any desire to do this speed running i'll cover this okay so go for it go for it in speed running there's any percent there's 100 and then there's another one i forgot the name of it it's effectively zero percent so so any percent means you just have to get to the title, the ending screen, right? Um, a hundred percent means there's a list of things you have to do, which, which they can constitute a hundred percent of the game and it's defined in advance and you have to get to the|||随着时间推移而被打破的。是的，这家伙太棒了。所以他给出了一个叙事性的历史，他做了所有这些工作。我当时在看关于《超级马里奥兄弟》的那期，里面有各种不同的分类，我对这个一无所知，也没有任何想要进行这种速通的欲望。我来介绍一下这个，好的，请讲，请讲。在速通中，有任意百分比（Any%），有 100%，然后还有另一个我忘了叫什么名字了，它实际上是 0%（Minimum%）。所以，任意百分比意味着你只需要到达标题、结局画面，对吧？嗯，100% 意味着有一系列你必须做的事情，这些事情构成了游戏的 100%，并且是提前定义好的，你必须到达
title screen. And then I think it's called mini percent, but basically it's a list of things that you're not allowed to do. Like for example, there's actually in Zelda two, I think it's a list of things that you're not allowed to do like for example there's actually in zelda 2 i think it's zelda 2 or one of the zelda maybe all the zeldas you can actually beat the game without getting the sword it's really hard but it's doable and so there's like a speed run of i think zelda 1 and zelda 2 where you have to beat the game without getting the sword that's called mini percent so there this guy has a variety some of the ones about like mario kart very interesting games you've played sometimes you watch a run and it looks like 75 of it just looks like very precise like very like cool stuff and then something will happen where he'll just walk
title screen. And then I think it's called mini percent, but basically it's a list of things that you're not allowed to do. Like for example, there's actually in Zelda two, I think it's a list of things that you're not allowed to do like for example there's actually in zelda 2 i think it's zelda 2 or one of the zelda maybe all the zeldas you can actually beat the game without getting the sword it's really hard but it's doable and so there's like a speed run of i think zelda 1 and zelda 2 where you have to beat the game without getting the sword that's called mini percent so there this guy has a variety some of the ones about like mario kart very interesting games you've played sometimes you watch a run and it looks like 75 of it just looks like very precise like very like cool stuff and then something will happen where he'll just walk|||标题画面。然后我认为它被称为最小百分比（mini percent），但基本上这是一系列你不被允许做的事情。比如，在《塞尔达传说 2》中，我认为这是一个你不被允许做的事情的列表，比如实际上在《塞尔达传说 2》中，我认为是《塞尔达传说 2》或是某个塞尔达游戏，也许所有的塞尔达游戏，你实际上不拿剑也能通关游戏，这真的很难，但这是可行的。所以有一个关于——我想是《塞尔达传说 1》和《塞尔达传说 2》的速通，你必须在不拿剑的情况下通关游戏，这被称为最小百分比。所以这个家伙有很多种视频，其中一些关于《马里奥赛车》等非常有趣的游戏，你玩过。有时你看一个速通流程，其中 75% 的部分看起来非常精准、非常酷，然后会发生一些事情，他会直接穿过
through a wall he'll be like wait a minute like what happened there and so there are i guess like there's rules about what's considered like a glitch and what's like an acceptable glitch and so like oh if you bypass the whole game you know like to jason saying that doesn't really count but if you're just like clipping through a wall then that's okay but what ends up happening is inadvertently they talk a lot about video game programming like oh you know mario runs at this speed in pixels which is a fractional amount because that's what they decided so there's this like sub pixel counter and so what someone's doing is they're trying to control this hidden variable get it into a certain spot and then go do something so that they get the highest probability of like this thing which is supposed to be random like
through a wall he'll be like wait a minute like what happened there and so there are i guess like there's rules about what's considered like a glitch and what's like an acceptable glitch and so like oh if you bypass the whole game you know like to jason saying that doesn't really count but if you're just like clipping through a wall then that's okay but what ends up happening is inadvertently they talk a lot about video game programming like oh you know mario runs at this speed in pixels which is a fractional amount because that's what they decided so there's this like sub pixel counter and so what someone's doing is they're trying to control this hidden variable get it into a certain spot and then go do something so that they get the highest probability of like this thing which is supposed to be random like|||一面墙，他会说“等一下，刚才那里发生了什么”。所以我想，关于什么被视为漏洞（glitch），什么事可接受的漏洞是有规则的，比如：哦，如果你绕过了整个游戏，就像杰森说的，那其实不算数；但如果你只是穿墙（clipping through a wall），那就可以了。但最终发生的情况是，他们在不知不觉中谈论了很多关于电子游戏编程的内容，比如：哦，你知道马里奥以这种像素速度奔跑，这是一个小数额，因为这是他们决定的。所以这里有一个亚像素计数器（sub pixel counter），有人在做的就是试图控制这个隐藏变量，把它弄到一个特定的位置，然后去执行某个动作，从而使本应随机的事情获得最高的概率，
reliably occurring and you just get into this very intertwined combination of like how and the 100 one this one that i i'll have in the show notes or if you just you know you can kind of look up it's brutal because it's many hours long because you have to play every level every mini boss every everything and sometimes you get to the very last level and there's something that's out of your control. It's just randomly the movement of this thing and you can get a really bad random number generator, RNG, and ruin a world record run, get to three hours in about perfect frame inputs.
reliably occurring and you just get into this very intertwined combination of like how and the 100 one this one that i i'll have in the show notes or if you just you know you can kind of look up it's brutal because it's many hours long because you have to play every level every mini boss every everything and sometimes you get to the very last level and there's something that's out of your control. It's just randomly the movement of this thing and you can get a really bad random number generator, RNG, and ruin a world record run, get to three hours in about perfect frame inputs.|||并可靠地发生。然后你就进入了这种高度交织的组合，比如如何……关于那个 100% 的视频，我会把它放在节目文稿中，或者如果你愿意，可以自己去查一下。它太残酷了，因为它长达好几个小时，因为你必须通关每一关、每一个小 boss、每一处细节。有时你到了最后一关，却有一些不受你控制的事情发生。仅仅是某个东西的随机移动，你就可能遇到非常糟糕的随机数生成器（RNG），从而毁掉一个世界纪录级别的速通，在完美帧输入进行了大约三个小时后，
And then all of a sudden it's just trashed because you drew bad. Yeah, it's unfreaking believable. My favorite of all of this is um i was watching so you know i'm a big fan of the final fantasy games you know i love the story and i was you know when i was younger and i had the time i would read a ton of fiction books and it really like kind of uh they touch that chord it's kind of you know what it did it connected the fiction books i was reading to video games.
And then all of a sudden it's just trashed because you drew bad. Yeah, it's unfreaking unbelievable. My favorite of all of this is um i was watching so you know i'm a big fan of the final fantasy games you know i love the story and i was you know when i was younger and i had the time i would read a ton of fiction books and it really like kind of uh they touch that chord it's kind of you know what it did it connected the fiction books i was reading to video games.|||突然之间，一切都泡汤了，因为你运气不好抽到了烂结果。是的，这简直难以置信。这里面我最喜欢的是——嗯，我当时在看，所以你知道我是《最终幻想》系列的超级粉丝，你知道我喜欢那个故事，而且你知道我年轻时有时间会读大量的小说，它真的触动了那种心弦，你知道它起到了什么作用：它把我正在读的小说和电子游戏连接在了一起。
Because up until then, there was Pac-Man, and then there were fiction books, which had this really deep plot and story, but were totally non-interactive. And they occupied two different worlds. And Final Fantasy, as primitive as it was, like the Super Nintendo or whatever, or the Nintendo, it connected those two worlds, which was really powerful for me. So I wanted to watch the
Because up until then, there was Pac-Man, and then there were fiction books, which had this really deep plot and story, but were totally non-interactive. And they occupied two different worlds. And Final Fantasy, as primitive as it was, like the Super Nintendo or whatever, or the Nintendo, it connected those two worlds, which was really powerful for me. So I wanted to watch the|||因为在此之前，只有《吃豆人》，然后是那些情节和故事非常深厚但完全没有互动性的小说。它们占据了两个不同的世界。而《最终幻想》，尽管它当时还很简陋，比如在超级任天堂（Super Nintendo）或别的什么主机上，或者在任天堂主机上，它把这两个世界连接在了一起，这对我来说非常有震撼力。所以我想看
final fantasy 4 which is in the u.s is called final fantasy 2 that speed run and uh i watched the any percent which means you just have to get to the ending screen however you can and so i'm watching this person's like yeah playing this like perfect game and doing things like you'd only do if you do what was coming ahead and everything right but then he gets to you know this um tower where this ruby gets stolen which is about like a fifth of the way through the game and the video is almost over and i'm just scratching my head here and basically what he found is there's a spell called warp and warp takes you up a level in a dungeon so if you're you know on like two levels down in a in in a dungeon. So if you're, you know, on like two levels down in an underground dungeon, it'll take you to one level. It doesn't take you out completely.
final fantasy 4 which is in the u.s is called final fantasy 2 that speed run and uh i watched the any percent which means you just have to get to the ending screen however you can and so i'm watching this person's like yeah playing this like perfect game and doing things like you'd only do if you do what was coming ahead and everything right but then he gets to you know this um tower where this ruby gets stolen which is about like a fifth of the way through the game and the video is almost over and i'm just scratching my head here and basically what he found is there's a spell called warp and warp takes you up a level in a dungeon so if you're you know on like two levels down in a in in a dungeon. So if you're, you know, on like two levels down in an underground dungeon, it'll take you to one level. It doesn't take you out completely.|||《最终幻想 4》（在美国被称为《最终幻想 2》）的速通，呃，我看了任意百分比（Any%）的速通，这意味着你只需要用任何可能的方法到达结局画面。所以我在看这个人——就像在玩一场完美的游戏，做着只有在预知未来走向时才会做的事，对吧？但接着他来到了，你知道的，这个红宝石被偷的塔，大约是游戏进程的五分之一左右，而视频快要结束了，我当时一头雾水。基本上他发现的是，有一个叫做 Warp（传送）的法术，Warp 可以带你在地牢里上一层楼。所以如果你在，你知道的，地牢里往下两层。所以如果你在，你知道的，地下地牢里往下两层，它会带你上一层。它不会把你完全带出去。
That's the exit spell. It'll take you like a little bit closer to the exit. And if you're going up a tower, you know, it takes you down. It takes you a little bit closer to the nearest town, right? But there's this one part of the game where the developers kind of forgot that they had to think about this warp spell and when you cast warp it just takes you into like random memory where you don't belong and he's walking around and as he's walking around like every tile is just random like and none of it is coherent and then he walks forward walks around and then all of a sudden
That's the exit spell. It'll take you like a little bit closer to the exit. And if you're going up a tower, you know, it takes you down. It takes you a little bit closer to the nearest town, right? But there's this one part of the game where the developers kind of forgot that they had to think about this warp spell and when you cast warp it just takes you into like random memory where you don't belong and he's walking around and as he's walking around like every tile is just random like and none of it is coherent and then he walks forward walks around and then all of a sudden|||那是 Exit（逃脱）法术。它会带你离出口更近一点。如果你在上塔，你知道的，它会带你往下走。它会让你离最近的城镇更近一点，对吧？但游戏中有这样一个部分，开发者们有点忘了去考虑这个 Warp 法术，当你施放 Warp 时，它会把你带到一个你不该去的随机内存地址中，他在里面走来走去，随着他走来走去，每一个格子都只是随机的，没有一个是连贯的，然后他向前走，四处走动，接着突然之间
he gets the ending credits i was like i was like okay all right i guess that happened if you're ever looking for though like i don't know it's like a very nerdy kind of documentary thing but it's just for me it's very easy to just like sit there and watch i don't know what about like the way these particular ones are done is just it's so easy to just tune out and just like yeah almost like in the background like it's not that i'm doing something else i'm just literally watching it but just like it's relaxing it's just yeah it's very like yeah i don't know meditative encourage you if you've never done it before i was gonna say that feels a little wrong but uh yeah if you've never watched one of these something so there's a few other individuals who also do uh descriptions
he gets the ending credits i was like i was like okay all right i guess that happened if you're ever looking for though like i don't know it's like a very nerdy kind of documentary thing but it's just for me it's very easy to just like sit there and watch i don't know what about like the way these particular ones are done is just it's so easy to just tune out and just like yeah almost like in the background like it's not that i'm doing something else i'm just literally watching it but just like it's relaxing it's just yeah it's very like i don't know meditative encourage you if you've never done it before i was gonna say that feels a little wrong but uh yeah if you've never watched one of these something so there's a few other individuals who also do uh descriptions|||他触发了片尾制作人员名单。我当时就想，好吧，好吧，我想事情就是这样发生的。如果你在寻找的话，虽然我不知道，这就像是一个非常书呆子气的纪录片，但对我来说，坐在那里观看非常轻松。我不知道这种特定的视频是怎么制作的，就是很容易让人放空，然后就像——几乎就像在背景里播放一样，并不是我在做别的事，我确实在看着它，但感觉很放松，就是，是的，非常像，我不知道，具有冥想性。如果你以前没看过的话，我鼓励你看一下。我本想说那感觉有点不对劲，但，呃，是的，如果你从来没看过这样的视频——Summoning Salt 以及其他一些也会进行这种限时速通解说的人，
of these time time runs which are also really good. There's, I guess, a community of them and they're all very good. Very cool. My first show topic is really wild. It's auto GPT reaches 100,000 stars. So, you know, it took PyTorch like multiple years to reach 100,000 stars. There's only two, as far as I know, there's only, well, now three GitHub projects have 100,000 stars. One is TensorFlow, one is PyTorch, and now we have AutoGPT.
of these time time runs which are also really good. There's, I guess, a community of them and they're all very good. Very cool. My first show topic is really wild. It's auto GPT reaches 100,000 stars. So, you know, it took PyTorch like multiple years to reach 100,000 stars. There's only two, as far as I know, there's only, well, now three GitHub projects have 100,000 stars. One is TensorFlow, one is PyTorch, and now we have AutoGPT.|||他们的视频也非常棒。我想他们形成了一个社区，而且他们都非常优秀。非常酷。我的第一个节目主题非常疯狂。那就是 AutoGPT 星标数达到 10万。所以，你知道，PyTorch 花了好几年时间才达到 10 万星标。据我所知，只有两个——好吧，现在有三个 GitHub 项目拥有 10 万星标。一个是 TensorFlow，一个是 PyTorch，现在我们有了 AutoGPT。
You know, to be honest, I've heard like the most insane stuff about AutoGPT. What I think it does is I think you go in and kind of like connect this to a bunch of other projects. But what I've heard are things like people have got auto GPT to like reduce their monthly payments. So this one guy said, you know, auto GPT, you know, here's all my tax forms. Here's all my banking statements, you know, reduce my monthly bill. And apparently auto GPT and this almost sounds fake, but I had to read it this multiple times to convince myself it's real. Auto GPT
You know, to be honest, I've heard like the most insane stuff about AutoGPT. What I think it does is I think you go in and kind of like connect this to a bunch of other projects. What I've heard are things like people have got auto GPT to like reduce their monthly payments. So this one guy said, you know, auto GPT, you know, here's all my tax forms. Here's all my banking statements, you know, reduce my monthly bill. And apparently auto GPT and this almost sounds fake, but I had to read it this multiple times to convince myself it's real. Auto GPT|||老实说，我听说过关于 AutoGPT 最疯狂的事情。我认为它的作用是，你可以进入并把它连接到其他一堆项目上。我听说过的事情比如有人让 AutoGPT 减少他们的月度支出。所以有个家伙说，你知道，AutoGPT，这是我所有的税表。这是我所有的银行对账单，帮我减少每月的账单。显然 AutoGPT——这听起来几乎像是假的，但我不得不读了好几遍来让自己相信它是真的。AutoGPT
found this like Wi-Fi airplane charge and said, hey, you can actually send an email to the airline company to cancel your Wi-Fi airplane charge because they don't do it anymore and they'll retroactively give you your money back. And it even drafted the email. And so he copied the email from AutoGPT, sent it to Verizon, and they credited him $30. And it also canceled some other things.
found this like Wi-Fi airplane charge and said, hey, you can actually send an email to the airline company to cancel your Wi-Fi airplane charge because they don't do it anymore and they'll retroactively give you your money back. And it even drafted the email. And so he copied the email from AutoGPT, sent it to Verizon, and they credited him $30. And it also canceled some other things.|||发现了这样一个飞机 Wi-Fi 费用，并说，嘿，你其实可以给航空公司发封电子邮件，取消你的飞机 Wi-Fi 费用，因为他们现在不再收取这项费用了，他们会追溯退还你的钱。它甚至起草了电子邮件。于是他复制了 AutoGPT 生成的邮件，发给 Verizon，对方退了他 30 美元。它还取消了一些其他的东西。
I don't know. I've just heard absolutely insane stories about this AutoGPT. I have a friend who is in finance and was using it to take care of some things, like with taxes and all of that. I have to really, you know, we should maybe do a whole show on this. I have to really wrap my head around what this is and like how it's different than just GPT-4 or, you know, chat GPT,
I don't know. I've just heard absolutely insane stories about this AutoGPT. I have a friend who is in finance and was using it to take care of some things, like with taxes and all of that. I have to really, you know, we should maybe do a whole show on this. I have to really wrap my head around what this is and like how it's different than just GPT-4 or, you know, chat GPT,|||我不知道。我只是听过关于这个 AutoGPT 的绝对疯狂的故事。我有一个在金融界的朋友，他一直在用它来处理一些事情，比如税务等等。我真的必须——你知道，我们也许应该专门做一期节目来聊聊这个。我必须真正搞清楚这到底是什么，以及它与单纯的 GPT-4 或你知道的 ChatGPT 有何不同，
but it's just blowing up in popularity. Yeah, there's a few of these self-pumping GPTs. So I watched a video on one because I was curious as well. And they are mashing together a bunch of tools. So there's a couple of like infrastructure plays. So there's like vector databases and there's a few paid and unpaid. And you can sort of connect them up to one of those.
but it's just blowing up in popularity. Yeah, there's a few of these self-pumping GPTs. So I watched a video on one because I was curious as well. And they are mashing together a bunch of tools. So there's a couple of like infrastructure plays. So there's like vector databases and there's a few paid and unpaid. And you can sort of connect them up to one of those.|||但它的热度确实在爆炸式增长。是的，有几个这种自我驱动的 GPT。所以我看了一个关于其中一个的视频，因为我也很好奇。它们把一堆工具揉合在了一起。所以有几个类似基础设施的角色。比如有向量数据库，还有一些付费的和免费的。你可以把它们连接到其中一个上面。
You can also just tell it to like do its work locally. There's various trade-offs depending on what computer you're on, like how much, you know, memory you can use. And we talked about like locally running some of these as well. And it'll use the like tokenizer from OpenAI. So you can kind of plug that in and just configure it on your computer. And it's not hosted.
You can also just tell it to like do its work locally. There's various trade-offs depending on what computer you're on, like how much, you know, memory you can use. And we talked about like locally running some of these as well. And it'll use the like tokenizer from OpenAI. So you can kind of plug that in and just configure it on your computer. And it's not hosted.|||你也可以直接告诉它在本地完成工作。根据你所使用的电脑，会有各种各样的权衡，比如你知道你可以使用多少内存。我们之前也讨论过在本地运行其中一些。它会使用来自 OpenAI 的分词器（tokenizer）。所以你可以把它接入并配置在你的电脑上。而且它不是托管的。
So different than going to like OpenAI and going into chat GPD and typing something, you're like connecting it or hosting your own sort of infrastructure. And the one that I watch is more or less, and you see this like, oh, it built me a website or whatever. And you sort of give it a task list, like something it's trying to accomplish. So when I watch was like, build me a
So different than going to like OpenAI and going into chat GPD and typing something, you're like connecting it or hosting your own sort of infrastructure. And the one that I watch is more or less, and you see this like, oh, it built me a website or whatever. And you sort of give it a task list, like something it's trying to accomplish. So when I watch was like, build me a|||所以这不同于去 OpenAI 并进入 ChatGPT 输入一些东西，你是在连接它或托管你自己的基础设施。我看的那个或多或少是这样的，你会看到诸如“哦，它给我建了一个网站”之类的内容。你基本上会给它一个任务列表，比如它试图完成的事情。所以我看的时候就像是：为我构建一个
healthy meal plan for this week. And so it tries to figure out, okay, what do I need to ask you to do that? And then I'll ask you some questions like, you know, hey, what kind of food allergies do you have or whatever, and you're kind of giving it answers. So rather than, you know, asking it questions, you're sort of saying, I want you to do these things and it's figuring out what order to tackle them in okay i'm going to build you thai food on monday and you can tell it to either go ahead and just do whatever it wants or the mode i was watching it was like prompting hey i want to issue a google search for like best thai dishes that are high in protein or something and it'll sort of figures out that query.
healthy meal plan for this week. And so it tries to figure out, okay, what do I need to ask you to do that? And then I'll ask you some questions like, you, hey, what kind of food allergies do you have or whatever, and you're kind of giving it answers. So rather than, you know, asking it questions, you're sort of saying, I want you to do these things and it's figuring out what order to tackle them in okay i'm going to build you thai food on monday and you can tell it to either go ahead and just do whatever it wants or the mode i was watching it was like prompting hey i want to issue a google search for like best thai dishes that are high in protein or something and it'll sort of figures out that query.|||本周的健康膳食计划。于是它试图弄清楚：好吧，我需要问你什么来完成这个？然后它会问你一些问题，比如，嘿，你对什么食物过敏之类的，而你则在回答它。所以，你不是在向它提问，而是在说：我希望你做这些事情，然后它会弄清楚以什么顺序来解决它们。好吧，我将在星期一为你做泰国菜，你可以告诉它直接随心所欲地去做，或者我看到的那个模式是在提示：嘿，我想针对蛋白质含量高的最佳泰国菜进行一次谷歌搜索之类的，然后它就会想出这个查询请求。
It'll issue it off to Google if you tell it to. And then it sort of scrapes and parses the feedback and decides what to do next. So rather than you saying, Hey, next I want you to do Tuesday. It knows, okay,
It'll issue it off to Google if you tell it to. And then it sort of scrapes and parses the feedback and decides what to do next. So rather than you saying, Hey, next I want you to do Tuesday. It knows, okay,|||如果你告诉它，它就会把请求发送给谷歌。然后它会抓取并解析反馈，决定下一步该做什么。所以，不是由你来说“嘿，接下来我要你做周二的”，而是它知道：好的，
I'm done with Monday. I'm going to go to Tuesday. Like now I'm building Tuesdays, Tuesday, I'm going to give you a, you know, burger and fries. And so like,
I'm done with Monday. I'm going to go to Tuesday. Like now I'm building Tuesdays, Tuesday, I'm going to give you a, you know, burger and fries. And so like,|||周一的完成了，我要进入周二了。就像现在我在制定周二的计划，周二我要给你安排，你知道的，汉堡和薯条。所以，
you know, I'm going to ask for something and it could burger and fries. And so like, you know, I'm going to ask for something and it could suggest for stuff it knows about, hey, I want to, you know, schedule an air schedule a door dash for you on Tuesday to like, get I know McDonald's burger size is terrible. But like, you know, and this is where those sort of kind of what I call like magical moments come in where it's like, oh, like, oh, that's really cool. I wouldn't have thought about that. Right.
you know, I'm going to ask for something and it could burger and fries. And so like, you know, I'm going to ask for something and it could suggest for stuff it knows about, hey, I want to, you know, schedule an air schedule a door dash for you on Tuesday to like, get I know McDonald's burger size is terrible. But like, you know, and this is where those sort of kind of what I call like magical moments come in where it's like, oh, like, oh, that's really cool. I wouldn't have thought about that. Right.|||你知道，我要点个东西，它可以是汉堡和薯条。所以，你知道的，我要点个东西，它可以推荐它知道的东西，嘿，我想要，你知道的，在周二为你安排一个外卖订单，去拿——我知道麦当劳的汉堡分量很糟糕。但是，你知道的，这就是那些我称之为“神奇时刻”的切入点，你会觉得：哦，哦，这真的很酷。我以前可没想过这一点。对吧。
And it's this sort of like more of an assistant thing rather than, you know, chatty agent on the other end. And I think that reformulation is pretty interesting. Yeah. It's tapping into all the state. Right. you had a plugin that like kept now this is itself an open ai problem but if you had like the state of your refrigerator somehow you know it could tap into that you could say you know make me thai food and it would say oh based on what you have in your pantry and your fridge like here's something you can make right now or like here's like the bare minimum you need to get from the
And it's this sort of like more of an assistant thing rather than, you know, chatty agent on the other end. And I think that reformulation is pretty interesting. Yeah. It's tapping into all the state. Right. you had a plugin that like kept now this is itself an open ai problem but if you had like the state of your refrigerator somehow you know it could tap into that you could say you know make me thai food and it would say oh based on what you have in your pantry and your fridge like here's something you can make right now or like here's like the bare minimum you need to get from the|||这更像是一种助手类的东西，而不是另一端那个只会闲聊的智能体。我认为这种重新表述非常有趣。是的。它在调用所有的状态。对吧。如果你有一个插件能够保持——现在这本身就是 OpenAI 的一个问题——但如果你不知何故拥有冰箱的状态，你知道它可以调用那个状态，你可以说“做一份泰国菜给我”，它就会说“哦，根据你食品储藏室和冰箱里现有的东西，这是你现在就能做的一道菜”或者“这是你需要从
store but it's like yeah adding that state think, is just like taking something that's already a breakthrough. And I think it's just making like breaking through another barrier. I think we'll see some really cool stuff. But I think we're also going to bump into some limitations where like, it's when it's sort of like initial and even today, if you try to ask the Google Assistant on Android, or you try to ask Siri on iOS, like or you try to ask siri on ios like or alexa when you ask it something it knows about it will give you like very incredible results and
store but it's like yeah adding that state think, is just like taking something that's already a breakthrough. And I think it's just making like breaking through another barrier. I think we'll see some really cool stuff. But I think we're also going to bump into some limitations where like, it's when it's sort of like initial and even today, if you try to ask the Google Assistant on Android, or you try to ask Siri on iOS, like or your try to ask siri on ios like or alexa when you ask it something it knows about it will give you like very incredible results and|||商店买的最低限度的东西”。但就像，是的，加入这种状态思考，就像是把一个已经是突破性的东西，再次推向另一个障碍的突破。我认为我们会看到一些非常酷的东西。但我认为我们也将会碰到一些局限性，比如，当它处于初期阶段时，甚至在今天，如果你试着问安卓上的谷歌助手，或者你试着问 iOS 上的 Siri，或者你试着问 iOS 上的 Siri，或者 Alexa，当你问它知道的事情时，它会给你非常不可思议的结果，
you'll think like it's really smart but then occasionally ask something like just off the beaten path or path or give it a phrasing that's equivalent but it doesn't understand that phrasing and it just it keels over and just gives you something like horrible and it's just like when you stay in the lane it's super cool but as soon as you get off the edge the like it's a very steep cliff and it just degrades there's no like graceful fallback and it often misunderstands you right like it thinks you're asking one thing you're asking actually something very different and so i think we're gonna run into the same one here i think there's this initial excitement and i think a lot of folks coming out and saying this is not something
you'll think like it's really smart but then occasionally ask something like just off the beaten path or path or give it a phrasing that's equivalent but it doesn't understand that phrasing and it just it keels over and just gives you something like horrible and it's just like when you stay in the lane it's super cool but as soon as you get off the edge the like it's a very steep cliff and it just degrades there's no like graceful fallback and it often misunderstands you right like it thinks you're asking one thing you're asking actually something very different and so i think we're gonna run into the same one here i think this is initial excitement and i think a lot of folks coming out and saying this is not something|||你会觉得它真的很聪明，但偶尔问一些稍微偏门的问题，或者用一个等效的表述去问它，而它却听不懂那个表述，它就会直接崩溃，给你一些糟糕透顶的回答。这就好像当你呆在车道内时它超级酷，但一旦你偏离边缘，就像是一个非常陡峭的悬崖，性能直接断崖式下跌，没有优雅的降级机制，而且它经常会误解你的意思，对吧？比如它以为你在问一件事，而你实际上在问完全不同的事。所以我想我们在这里也会遇到同样的问题，我认为这是最初的兴奋，而且我认为很多人站出来说，这并不是
that ai researchers sort of predicted but like the practical application sort of like got there a initial excitement. And I think a lot of folks coming out and saying, this is not something that AI researchers sort of predicted, but like the practical application sort of like got there a lot faster. And sort of like, the question is, where does it tap out? Like, do we hit a, you know, asymptotic slowdown and sort of like need the next unlocking and there was some, you know, open AI stuff saying they're not going to just grow the network again, they need to go think about architecture and, you know and how to be more efficient. They can't just keep adding more parameters. Yeah.
that AI researchers sort of predicted, but like the practical application sort of like got there a lot faster. And sort of like, the question is, where does it tap out? Like, do we hit a, you know, asymptotic slowdown and sort of like need the next unlocking and there was some, you know, open AI stuff saying they're not going to just grow the network again, they need to go think about architecture and, you know and how to be more efficient. They can't just keep adding more parameters. Yeah.|||人工智能研究人员预料到的事情，但实际应用的发展速度要快得多。这就好比，问题是，它的极限在哪里？比如，我们是否会遇到渐近式放缓，从而需要下一次的技术解锁？而且有一些 OpenAI 的内部消息说，他们不会再次盲目扩大网络规模，他们需要去思考架构以及如何变得更加高效。他们不能只是不断增加参数。是的。
I mean, actually, a lot of different ways to take that. But one thing I wanted to say really quick, because I've seen this come up a lot. I've actually had people ask me this. So people working in AI research for like, you know, FANG companies or Open AI, like we're not all part of a CIA operation. Let me just get this out there. I've had people like tell me like, oh, this is all like run by the government or everyone's like a state actor or whatever.
I mean, actually, a lot of different ways to take that. But one thing I wanted to say really quick, because I've seen this come up a lot. I've actually had people ask me this. So people working in AI research for like, you know, FANG companies or Open AI, like we're not all part of a CIA operation. Let me just get this out there. I've had people like tell me like, oh, this is all like run by the government or everyone's like a state actor or whatever.|||我的意思是，实际上有很多不同的理解方式。但我有一件事想快点说，因为我看到这种情况经常出现。实际上有人问过我这个问题。所以那些在 FANG 公司或 OpenAI 等机构从事人工智能研究的人，我们并不是全都是 CIA（中央情报局）特工行动的一部分。让我先把话说清楚。有人对我说：哦，这一切都是由政府操控的，或者每个人都是国家行为体之类的。
And no, it's not. I've not heard this. This is news to me. I didn't know you worked for the CIA. I don't know why I keep getting this. But like, no, like, like, and so like, you know, I think you're right that people in AI are just as surprised as anybody else that it took off. I mean, you know, it's actually been incremental, you know, on the research side, but it just
And no, it's not. I've not heard this. This is news to me. I didn't know you worked for the CIA. I don't know why I keep getting this. But like, no, like, like, and so like, you know, I think you're right that people in AI are just as surprised as anybody else that it took off. I mean, you know, it's actually been incremental, you know, on the research side, but it just|||才没有这回事。我从来没听过这个。这对我来说是新闻。我不知道你在 CIA 工作。我不知道为什么我总听到这种说法。但，不，就像——所以，你知道，我觉得你说得对，人工智能领域的人和其他人一样，对它的爆发感到非常惊讶。我的意思是，你知道，在研究方面它其实一直是渐进式发展的，但
the way the commercial applicability, like the way that that just took off really surprised everyone. I know people at OpenAI and they're surprised. And so there is no like conspiracy here uh everyone this is just like one of those like uh you know when you're playing civilization and you just get a breakthrough or something randomly like it's just one of those things there's no there's no secret that i do feel like, you know, it's going to have a big impact, even as is I think copywriters, I actually got a spam call, which was I'm pretty sure a GPT based spam call. Because, you know, it had like my name, and it was like, it felt like a real person, but it was, it was like in the uncanny valley. So I knew it was a recording, but it was so contextual that I thought, well, let me just see where this goes. So I said, yeah, this is me. This is Jason.
the way the commercial applicability, like the way that that just took off really surprised everyone. I know people at OpenAI and they're surprised. And so there is no like conspiracy here uh everyone this is just like one of those like uh you know when you're playing civilization and you just get a breakthrough or something randomly like it's just one of those things there's no there's no secret that i do feel like, you know, it's going to have a big impact, even as is I think copywriters, I actually got a spam call, which was I'm pretty sure a GPT based spam call. Because, you know, it had like my name, and it was like, it felt like a real person, but it was, it was like in the uncanny valley. So I knew it was a recording, but it was so contextual that I thought, well, let me just see where this goes. So I said, yeah, this is this is Jason.|||商业应用的方式，也就是那种爆发的势头，真的让所有人都大吃一惊。我认识 OpenAI 的人，他们也很惊讶。所以这里没有什么阴谋，各位，这就像是那种——你知道当你玩《文明》游戏时，突然随机获得了一项突破之类的——它就是那种事情之一，没有什么秘密。我确实觉得，你知道的，它会产生巨大的影响，即使是以目前的形式。我认为文案创作者，我实际上接到过一个垃圾电话，我非常确定那是一个基于 GPT 的垃圾电话。因为，你知道，它提到了我的名字，而且感觉像是一个真人，但它处于恐怖谷（uncanny valley）里。所以我知道这是一段录音，但它的语境是如此贴切，以至于我想：好吧，让我看看这通电话会怎么发展。所以我说：好的，我是杰森。
And then it like went off and like said this whole monologue and I couldn't interrupt it and I hung up. But like, you know, that first part, I think, was actually done by like that's more text to speech, I guess, than GPT. But I guess we're just getting to the point where like I think it's more text to speech i guess than gpt but um i guess we're just getting to the point where like i think it's really gonna have like all this research you've been doing is really gonna have some effect on the world which is kind of wild and like anything it's going to have you know a thousand positive effects 999 negative effects and hopefully it will be slightly
And then it like went off and like said this whole monologue and I couldn't interrupt it and I hung up. But like, you know, that first part, I think, was actually done by like that's more text to speech, I guess, than GPT. But I guess we're just getting to the point where like I think it's more text to speech i guess than gpt but um i guess we're just getting to the point where like i think it's really gonna have like all this research you been doing is really gonna have some effect on the world which is kind of wild and like anything it's going to have you know a thousand positive effects 999 negative effects and hopefully it will be slightly|||然后它就开始滔滔不绝地发表这段独白，我无法打断它，于是我挂断了电话。但是，你知道的，第一部分，我认为实际上是由——比起 GPT，那更像是文字转语音（TTS）。但我猜我们正处于这样一个阶段，我猜比起 GPT，这更像是文字转语音，但嗯，我猜我们正处于这样一个阶段，我真的认为你一直在做的所有这些研究最终都会对世界产生一些影响，这有点疯狂，就像任何事物一样，它会有，你知道的，一千个积极影响和九百九十九个消极影响，希望它会稍微好一点。
better at the end okay we can dwell on this but'm going to keep us moving because I have a lot of thoughts here. So my next is, I guess I could have made a book a show, but whatever here it's here in the news links, which is build your own database from scratch. And this is free online, but they also have a print version that you can purchase by James Smith, who actually has a couple other similar style books of build something from scratch. I will disclaim I have it is why it's in the new section of the book section. I haven't actually read this book yet. But I did skim through the topics. I have it as like my perpetually growing list of bookmarks, which is my steam backlog. But you know, I'm trying I want to kind of go through this about, you know, how do you start with key value store, B trees, that kind of stuff, move to relational queries,
最后会变好，好吧，我们可以纠结于此，但我得继续往下讲，因为我对这有很多想法。所以我的下一个，我想我本可以把一本书做成一个节目，但管他呢，它现在就在新闻链接里，也就是“从头构建你自己的数据库”（Build Your Own Database from Scratch）。这是网上免费的，但你也可以购买由詹姆斯·史密斯（James Smith）撰写的印刷版，他其实还有几本其他类似风格的“从头构建某物”的书。我要声明我有这本书，这也是它为什么会出现在节目的图书板块。我其实还没读过这本书。但我浏览了里面的主题。我把它放在我那个永远在增加的书签列表里，也就是我的Steam游戏库积压清单。但你知道，我在尝试，我想了解一下，比如，你是如何从键值存储、B树之类的内容开始，过渡到关系型查询，
query planning, query execution. What I will say is, I took a database course in college. They were, I feel like it missed a lot because it kind of went into the, what is that called? Sort of relational algebra stuff, whatever that, I just really,
查询规划，查询执行的。我要说的是，我上大学时修过一门数据库课程。我觉得它遗漏了很多东西，因为它深入探讨了，那叫什么来着？某种关系代数之类的东西，不管那叫什么，我真的
I wasn't going to be an academic researcher. It wasn't interesting to me. Yeah, this is a total blind spot for me. I mean, I use databases, but I have no idea how. Oh, I'm about to talk about you. Hold tight one second. But I was forced to learn SQL as well as part of that, like the practical portion of the course. And then I kind of forgot about it. I did a bunch of embedded work and it was no nothing. Then when I moved to Silicon Valley, one of my early jobs required me to write a lot of SQL and really learn sort of joints. And I'm by no means an expert. But what I realized after
不打算当学术研究员。我对这个不感兴趣。是的，这是我的一个彻底盲区。我的意思是，我使用数据库，但完全不知道它是如何运作的。哦，我正要谈到你。稍等一下。但我当时也被迫学习了SQL，作为该课程实践部分的一部分。然后我就把这事儿给忘了。我做了一堆嵌入式开发，然后就彻底抛到脑后了。后来当我搬到硅谷时，我早期的工作之一要求我编写大量的SQL，并真正学会了各种连接（join）。我绝不是什么专家。但我学习之后的体会是，
learning it is, even if you're not going to use SQL day to day, and people who don't, I've begun to realize there's people who are very scared of it, or slash don't know it. And so they'll do anything they can to not have to write a SQL query. And then people who know it are just like, oh yeah, I'll turn one of those out for you, no problem. And there's this wrap. And we've had a series of interviews, really great interviews with people trying to kind of say, stop worrying how this like 10 year ago mentality
即使你日常不用SQL——我开始意识到确实有些人非常害怕SQL，或者说/根本不懂SQL。所以他们会想尽一切办法不去写SQL查询。而懂SQL的人就会觉得：“哦，行吧，我给你现写一个，没问题。”这里面存在一种差距。我们之前做过一系列采访，是非常棒的采访，采访对象试图指出：别再担心那种十年前的陈旧思维了——
that if you have a relational database in your stack, you're doomed to not scale. Like this is not a problem that it used to be. It's still something to consider, but there's a lot of workarounds for it. There's a problem that it used to be it's still something to consider but there's a lot of workarounds for there's a lot better tech stack now around it but we sort of a lot of people not that you've sort of self-incriminated but kind of like fell into this like i'm not going to write sql queries and i'm going to use this crutch excuse that like well wait wait i'm not that but no i use the sql query i just don't actually know
如果你在技术栈里用关系型数据库，你就注定无法扩展。这已经不再是过去那种问题了。它依然是需要考虑的事情，但有很多变通的方法。它不再是以前那样的难题了，依然需要权衡，但有很多变通的方法，现在周围有更好得多的技术栈。但我们很多人——倒不是说你已经自证其罪——有点陷入了这种“我才不写SQL查询呢，我要用这个拐杖来当借口，说什么……等一下，等一下，我可不是那样，不，我用SQL查询，我只是实际上对数据库底层是如何工作的
a lot about how databases work under the hood oh okay all right well then you're not the one i'm talking about we'll get to you in a second i also don't know how it runs and i'm not a great sql query writer but i know enough to like get it done and i think there's a lot of unlock there that happens when you sort of know how to do joins you know how to do do where clauses, and just, yes, you could do it in Python. That's why everyone said, oh, I could just do it in Python. I could just open this and open that. But if you're going to do a bunch of ad hoc queries, like many of them,
知之甚少。”哦，好吧，好吧，那你就不是我刚才说的那种人。我们一会儿再聊到你。我其实也不知道它底层是怎么运行的，而且我也不是个出色的SQL查询编写者，但我懂的足够让我把事情搞定。我觉得，当你大致知道怎么写连接（joins），知道怎么写WHERE子句时，会解锁很多能力。是的，你完全可以用Python来做。这就是为什么每个人都说：“哦，我用Python就能搞定。我只要打开这个，打开那个就行。”但如果你要做一堆即席查询（ad hoc queries），比如很多个这样的查询，
and each of them are sort of ephemeral, you just want to do them once, get your answer and be done. And you're never going to run it again. You don't really care about it. There is a value to having a bunch of data crammed into a database. I'm going to refer to this in my tool of the show. But is a value to having a bunch of data crammed into a database. I'm going to refer to this in my tool to show, but just, you know, that style of data available,
而且每一个都是临时的，你只想做一次，得到答案就完事了，再也不会运行第二次了。你根本不在乎它。把一堆数据塞进数据库里是有价值的。我会在今天的“本期推荐工具”里提到这个。但把一堆数据塞进数据库里确实有价值。我会在今天的“本期推荐工具”里提到这一点，不过，你知道，那种风格的数据随时可用，
so you can run your analysis and get out. Not everyone has to do that, but it occasionally comes up. And sort of just writing a Python script takes a lot longer, because you can do more, it can, it's more flexible, it's more powerful, yes, but that's not what you're looking for. And so a lot of people are really hesitant. I found, for whatever reason, from traditional CS backgrounds, it's like a stigma, I think, from database administrators from a while ago. No one wanted to get into that job. They didn't appreciate that job.
这样你就可以运行分析然后收工。并不是每个人都必须这样做，但这偶尔会派上用场。仅仅去写一个Python脚本要花更多时间，因为你可以做更多事，它更灵活、功能更强大，是的，但那并不是你想要的。所以很多人非常犹豫。我发现，不管出于什么原因，传统计算机科学背景的人身上有一种污名，我觉得这是从以前的数据库管理员那里继承来的。没有人想去干那份工作。他们不欣赏那份工作。
I have a ton of respect for those people, but I think it was a thankless job for a long time. I think that's changed. And anyways, there's a real off topic. I think I'm really excited to check this book out. Like you said, Jason, I also, I know what B-trees are. I know that they're used in databases. I get sort of the vague thing, but how is indexing done?
我对那些人充满了敬意，但我认为在很长一段时间里，那是一份吃力不讨好的工作。我想这种情况已经改变了。不管怎样，这扯得有点远了。我觉得我真的很兴奋能看看这本书。就像你说的，杰森，我也一样，我知道什么是B树。我知道它们被用在数据库里。我大概了解个模糊的概念，但是索引是怎么完成的？
How are relational queries like optimized? This is super fascinating to me. I would love to learn more. And it feeds into my like general diatribe about like, hey, embrace SQL, stop hating it. Yeah, I actually, I've been in exactly the same position where so many people do Python or even C or C++ to analyze some data files. And there's actually an amazing tool called DuckDB. Oh, almost had that as my tool of the show.
关系型查询是如何被优化的？这对我来说超级吸引人。我很想了解更多。这也契合了我一直以来的长篇大论，那就是：嘿，拥抱SQL吧，别再讨厌它了。对啊，其实，我也经历过完全相同的处境：很多人用Python甚至C或C++来分析一些数据文件。其实有一个很棒的工具叫DuckDB。哦，我差点把这个当作我本期推荐的工具！
Oh, that's literally your tool of the show? No, no, no, no, no, no. I almost did. Oh, almost did DuckDB. Oh, almost had that as my tool of the show. Oh, that's literally your tool of the show? No, no, no, no, no, no. I almost did. Oh, almost did DuckDB. Okay. TLDR, DuckDB is a way where you can take files on your computer, like CSVs, your column separated files and all of that, and you can write SQL queries against them. And yeah, I mean, the thing about SQL is nothing beats it as well, except maybe Perl, but nothing beats SQL in terms of being short and, you know, doing what you want. Yeah, I think SQL is much more readable than Perl. So I would say SQL is really the best if performance isn't, you know, super critical and you want to, you know, synthesize some data. SQL is just absolutely amazing another rant
哦，这真的是你本期推荐的工具吗？不，不，不，不，不，不。我差点就选这个了。哦，差点选了DuckDB。哦，我差点把它当成我本期推荐的工具。哦，那真的是你本期推荐的工具吗？不，不，不，不，不，不。我差点选了。哦，差点选了DuckDB。好吧。简而言之（TLDR），DuckDB是一种工具，你可以用它来处理电脑上的文件，比如CSV文件、逗号分隔文件以及所有这些，然后你可以针对它们编写SQL查询。而且，关于SQL最棒的一点是，没有什么能比得上它，也许Perl除外，但就简短性以及“实现你想要的功能”而言，没有什么能比得上SQL。是的，我觉得SQL比Perl可读性强得多。所以我想说，如果性能不是超级关键，而且你想综合处理一些数据，SQL绝对是最好的。这又是我们可以长篇大论的一个话题，
we could get on we will have to come back to this later yeah totally yeah um man yeah i mean we're uh some of these things like we're recursively generating more episode we are rgpt yeah we have we have ptgpt so cool my my second one is asking generative art AI to render mathematical theorems. And so what this person did is they, as it suggests, they took a bunch of mathematical theorems and they put it into mid journey, which if you don't know, mid journey is similar to DALI or one of these other ones where you just type in a text prompt and they generate a picture. And so this person put in these math theorems as text prompts and the pictures they generate are awesome. I mean, they're not, you know, you can't recover the theorem or anything like that, but it's just like these crazy kind of like repeating structures. So like, for example he has um the uh the bear category theorem which states in a complete metric space the intersection of countably many dense sets remains dense and so he puts that into
我们得留到以后再聊了。对，完全是，对。天哪，真是……有些事情就像我们在递归地生成更多期节目一样，我们就是GPT。对，我们有PTGPT。太酷了。我的第二个话题是：让生成式艺术AI来渲染数学定理。所以这个人做的事是，正如你所猜想的，他们拿了一堆数学定理，然后把它们输入到Midjourney中——如果你不知道的话，Midjourney类似于DALL-E或其他一些工具，你只需输入一段文本提示词，它们就能生成一张图片。于是这个人把这些数学定理作为文本提示词输入进去，生成的图片太棒了。我的意思是，它们并不是……你知道的，你无法从图片中还原出定理或类似的东西，但它们就像是那种疯狂的、重复的结构。比如，他有
mid journey and what you get out of it is this like fractal of of like new age architecture it's like these buildings that are kind of embedded inside of a a very sort of like 3d cubist kind of environment and they're just fractally you know going off into into this like fixed point in the distance now let's just say like another one i thought was really cool was uh every vector space has a hamil basis that would be really hard right because you know even a gpt system probably isn't you know like it's seen hamil basis so rarely that it's probably not in there but what it generated was like a bunch of planets in this like uh space uh you know universe and the planets are like some of them are just floating but then some of the planets are trapped inside this cube that it
贝尔范畴定理（Baire category theorem），该定理指出：在一个完备度量空间中，可数个稠密集之交集仍然是稠密的。所以他把这个输入到
looks like it's being assembled in real time and you know there's this is all just a static image but you kind of get this feeling of time and And then underneath the universe, there's like an aurora. And standing on the aurora is like a family, like looking at the whole thing. It's just amazing. I mean, any of these would be just phenomenal portraits to have in your house or at your dorm room or something. So, yeah, check these out. It's definitely pretty cool. I candy. Yeah. I feel like I'm not, I will admit, like I'm not a sort of art appreciator historian.
Midjourney里，出来的是这样一个分形，呈现出新时代建筑的风格——就像是那些嵌入在一个非常类似于3D立体主义环境中的建筑，它们呈分形状一直延伸到远处的某个不动点。现在，另一个我觉得非常酷的定理是：每一个向量空间都有一个哈梅尔基（Hamel basis）。这应该很难吧，因为你知道，甚至连GPT系统大概也没怎么见过哈梅尔基基，它见得太少了，所以大概不在它的训练数据里。但它生成的是在这个类似太空宇宙中的一堆行星，有些行星只是漂浮着，但有些行星被困在一个正在实时组装的立方体里面。
Like I go to museums and I enjoy looking at them, but I don't, I don't know, get into sort of the background explanation, like the cause or the feeling of it, but just like going and appreciating like the craft or the novelness of doing these remind me of these procedural gener generative art stuff which is which is pretty cool because they're not generating code to generate the thing they're just generating it directly right but it definitely picks up that style there are some weird nuances like this one about every prime number greater than one or every number greater than one can be represented as a product
你看，这虽然只是一张静态图像，但你能感受到时间和空间。然后在宇宙的下方，就像是一道极光。站在极光旁边就像是一个家庭，正看着这一切。这简直太惊艳了。我的意思是，其中任何一张都可以挂在你家或宿舍里作为超级震撼的肖像画。所以，去看看这些吧，绝对非常酷，绝对是视觉大餐。是的。我觉得我不是……我承认，我不是那种艺术鉴赏家或艺术史学家。
of prime numbers and it has a bunch of numbers on the globe but the numbers are really distorted it's kind of interesting like it's an interesting piece to look at but yeah it's kind of funny how it kind of knows what numbers look like but it doesn't actually know what are valid numbers so you get kind of like a rune set it's kind of yeah this one is wild this a bit a bit weird but yeah definitely cool to look at i i mean if nothing else i could totally see me as not a art background person doing something like this and then like using as inspiration to like clean it up and do my own thing it's sort of the you know yeah growing up i had that or whatever, like, or when I was a younger programmer, like someone just give me an interesting problem.
就像我去博物馆参观时很享受看展的过程，但我不会去探究那些背景解释、背后的原因或情感。不过去欣赏那种工艺或是这样做的创新性，让我想起了那些程序化生成的艺术作品，这真的很酷，因为它们不是通过编写代码来生成事物，而是直接生成的，对吧？但它绝对捕捉到了那种风格。这里面有一些奇怪的细微差别，比如关于“每个大于1的素数”或者“每个大于1的整数都可以表示为素数的乘积”的那一个，它在地球仪上放了一堆数字，但这些数字被严重扭曲了。这挺有意思的——这是一个很有看头的作品。但这也挺搞笑的，它好像知道数字长什么样，但实际上并不知道什么是合数，所以你最终得到的是一堆类似符文的东西。这有点……是的，这个太疯狂了，有点诡异，但绝对很酷，值得一看。我的意思是，退一万步讲，我完全可以想象自己作为一个没有艺术背景的人，做出这样的东西，然后把它用作灵感去润色，创作出我自己的作品。这就有点像……是的，
Like, I feel like I have tools, but I don't know what problem to solve. They're like, you could go here, type one of these, get like inspiration and then just go make the art you want to see. Like, oh, this is really cool. I'm going to go do that.
我成长的时候就有过那种经历，或者说当我还是个年轻程序员的时候，别人给我一个有趣的问题。就像我觉得自己手里有工具，但不知道该解决什么问题。他们会说：“你可以去这儿，输入其中一个，获得灵感，然后去创作你想看到的艺术。”哦，这太酷了。我要去搞一个。
And it's sort of akin, but like an on-demand search of a lot of folks start their art by copying existing art and sort of learning what makes it that and so i feel like this could be the same thing except like you're not copying someone so you don't run into the same like what's derivative versus like plagiarism i got i have a mind-blowing idea okay okay all right let's go so if anyone does this you know i don't have to be
这有点类似，但就像是对很多人的按需搜索：很多人开始做艺术时，是通过临摹现有的艺术，并去了解是什么造就了它。所以我觉得这可以是同一回事，只不过你不是在临摹某个人，因此你不会陷入那种“什么是衍生作品”与“什么是抄袭”的争论中。我有了一个颠覆认知的主意！好啊，好啊，来吧。所以如果有人做了这个，你知道，我不需要
like get shares of your company but i at least want to get added on at it on twitter so here's my idea okay it's a little bit creepy it's one of these things it's like you can't tell if this is creepy or cool um you tell me patrick creepy or cool so you get a digital picture frame like a digital portrait right so so like imagine like a large canvas portrait but it's it's a big screen, right? And so you hang that up on your wall and it's got a microphone. And so it listens to your conversations, right? And then in some privacy preserving way,
分到你公司的股份，但我至少希望能被在推特（Twitter）上@一下。所以这是我的想法，好吧？这稍微有点诡异。这就是那种你分不清这到底是诡异还是酷的东西……你告诉我，帕特里克：诡异还是酷？你买一个数码相框，比如一个数码肖像画，对吧？所以——想象一下，一个大的画布肖像，但它是一个大屏幕，对吧？然后你把它挂在墙上，它带有一个麦克风。所以它会倾听你们的对话，对吧？然后以某种保护隐私的方式，
Hand wave. Sends a, maybe it's running Dolly locally. I don't know yet, but let's say it takes you know the conversations you're having in your house and it creates art based on the things you're saying in your own house and it displays the art so if you're if you start i know this this is gonna go sideways really fast so if you have an argument you know even the pictures start getting angry i think this would be wild i mean i think it would take a lot of tuning to know like what's appropriate what's not appropriate that's what i was gonna say also like you're having a conversation about someone who's not in the room and then they come into the room and like yeah like you have a conversation like you know so and so is so rude and then like well unless
挥手动作。发送一个……也许它在本地运行DALL-E，我目前还不知道，但假设它知道你在家里进行的对话，并根据你在自己家里说的话来创作艺术，然后把艺术展示出来。所以，如果你开始……我知道这事儿很快就会失控。所以如果你和人吵架，你知道，连画作都会开始变得愤怒。我觉得这会疯狂。我的意思是，这需要大量的调整才能知道什么是合适的，什么是不合适的。我正要这么说。而且，如果你在谈论一个不在房间里的人，然后他们走进了房间，然后……对，就像你们在聊天时说“某某人太粗鲁了”，然后……好吧，除非
they're famous you know it's not going to show them but it's going to show just like a rude person on the wall or oh so you have privacy preserving microphones but the cameras that's too creepy like you it's never going to learn who people are that crosses the line oh yeah so you can listen to what you are but right right so it's okay oh that's an interesting idea i hadn't even thought about the camera angle like maybe maybe, oh, what about this? I got it. I got it. Okay.
他们是名人，否则它不会展示他们，它只会展示墙上一个粗鲁的人，或者……哦，所以你有保护隐私的麦克风，但摄像头就太诡异了？就像它永远不会知道人是谁，这越界了。哦，对，所以它可以听你们在说什么，但……没错，没错。所以这没问题。哦，这是个有趣的主意，我甚至都没想到摄像头角度的问题，也许……也许，这个怎么样？我想到了。我想到了，好吧。
So this might be more practical. It has a camera and it draws like a caricature of whoever's sitting on the couch. That could be cool. Like a court portrait kind of thing. Yeah. Like, you know, when you go to... Someone's getting offended really fast. You go to like a tourist destination and they will draw like your caricature, you know when you go to someone's getting offended really fast you go to like a tourist destination
所以这可能更实用。它配有一个摄像头，然后给坐在沙发上的任何人画一幅讽刺漫画。那可能挺酷的。就像法庭肖像画那种感觉。对，就像，当你去……有人很快就被冒犯了。当你去旅游景点时，他们会给你画讽刺漫画，你知道的，当你去……有人很快就被冒犯了。当你去旅游景点时，
and they will draw like your caricature you know and it's basically the same three the same theme everyone kind of looks more or less the same like giant i don't know why body when i tried this mine just keeps drawing me as a professional bodybuilder so i i mean i i think oh man this would be uh really well i wonder if i have a you know i actually have a spare monitor i wonder if i could mount a spare monitor on the wall in the living room actually make this uh this i mean i guess you have to add us on twitter if you do or add us on twitter is like you add all of twitter oh man yeah that's that's awesome all right we'll go to book of the show add us on Twitter is like you add all of Twitter. Oh man.
他们会给你画讽刺漫画，你知道的，基本上就是那三个主题，每个人看起来都大同小异，有着巨大的……我不知道为什么身体。当我尝试这个时，它总是把我画成一个职业健美运动员。所以，我想……天哪，这真的很棒。我在想我是不是……我其实有一个闲置显示器，我在想我是不是可以在客厅墙上装一个闲置显示器，然后把这个弄出来……我的意思是，如果你这样做了，你得在推特上@我们，或者在推特上@我们就像把整个推特都@了一遍。天哪，太棒了。好吧，我们进入本期推荐图书。在推特上@我们就像把整个推特都@了一遍。天哪，
Yeah, that's awesome. All right, we'll go to book of the show. Book of the show. My book of the show, actually speaking about retro is an app. I think it's on iPhone,
太棒了。好吧，我们进入本期推荐图书。本期推荐图书。我本期推荐的图书，实际上说到复古，是一款应用。我想它在iPhone上架了，
but it's definitely on Android called fighting fantasy classics. So for people who don't know, there were a bunch of books called Fighting Fantasy Books made by Steve Jackson and Ian Livingstone. And they're basically choose your own adventure books, but you need dice, so you have to bring your own dice. And along the way, you occasionally have to roll dice and certain things happen. And you can actually get to a point where, you know, you just roll badly and you lose. But there's also an adventure sheet. So the idea is you would Xerox the adventure sheet to make copy of it. And you would keep track in the adventure
但它绝对在Android上也有，叫做《战斗幻想经典》（Fighting Fantasy Classics）。所以对于不知道的人来说，以前有一堆书叫做《战斗幻想》系列丛书，由史蒂夫·杰克逊（Steve Jackson）和伊恩·利文斯托（Ian Livingstone）创作。它们基本上是“选择你自己的冒险”类书籍，但你需要骰子，所以你得自己带骰子。在整个过程中，你偶尔需要掷骰子，然后会发生某些特定的事情。你甚至可能会遇到这样的情况：你知道，你 просто 运气不好，掷了个烂点数，然后就输了。但这里也有一张冒险记录单。所以原本的做法是，你要用复印机复印冒险记录单来使用。你需要在冒险
sheet of your equipment and your health and all of that. And so based on the choices you make, you might make a choice that says, you know, lose one stamina or roll the that. And so based on the choices you make, like you might make a choice that says, you know, lose one stamina or roll the dice. And if it's, you know, 10 or less, you lose a stamina. And if you lose, if any of your attributes go to zero, that's it. So if your skill goes to zero, you're kind of just like incapacitated, your stamina goes to zero, you're dead. I think your luck could go to zero and then you just lose every luck roll after that. And so, you know, the books were amazing, really great stories. There are about 400 sections. There'd be multiple sections in a page. So, you know, at the top right, there's sort of the page count, but instead of going one, two, three, four, you know, like one
记录单上记录你的装备、生命值以及所有这些数据。因此，根据你做出的选择，你可能会做一个选择，上面写着“失去1点体力”或者“掷骰子”。因此，根据你做出的选择，你可能会做一个选择，上面写着：失去1点体力，或者掷骰子。如果点数是10或更低，你就失去1点体力。如果你输了，如果你任何一个属性归零，那就结束了。所以如果你的技巧归零，你基本上就失去了行动能力；如果你的体力归零，你就死了。我想你的幸运值也可以归零，然后之后你每次幸运判定都会失败。所以，你知道，这些书太棒了，故事非常精彩。大约有400个小节。一页上会有多个小节。所以，你知道，在右上角有页码计数，但它不是一、二、三、四这样，你知道的，比如一
page might be, you know, one through seven or something, because it's seven short things telling you to like go to the next section. I love these as a kid, I thought the stories were great, a lot of really interesting themes that I think they're really exploring, you know, nowadays, everything is either, you know, zombies or World War Two, or, you know, space Marines. But, you know, in a lot of these fighting fantasy books are some really exotic, you you know worlds that they were putting together here you know some became tropes like space assassin but then other ones i'm trying to remember one of the more esoteric ones there was oh there was um one i think it was called uh battle with evil but evil was an acronym e-v-i-l or it was like date with evil. And it was basically this like technocratic future where
页可能包含一到七节左右，因为里面有七个简短的内容，指示你跳转到下一个小节。我小时候超爱这些书，我觉得故事太棒了，里面有很多非常有趣的隐喻，我觉得他们当时真的很深入地在探索这些。你知道，现在什么都是僵尸、二战、或是太空陆战队员。但在许多《战斗幻想》书籍中，有一些非常异国情调的、
everyone has crazy augmentations and stuff. I loved it. And anyways, with this app, you can go and buy all these old books. And so I think it's like a dollar or two bucks a book. The app comes with one for free. And I've been really getting into it. It's been a blast. I've been getting my kids into it. You know, depending on the Depending on the book, some of them might be more like you might need to have older kids. There's one that was something from hell, creature from hell or something like that. It's pretty demonic. I think it would give one of my kids nightmares. You have to judge whether you want to be up all night with your kid the night after.
你知道的他们构建的世界。有些变成了俗套，比如太空刺客，但其他的——我正努力回想其中一个比较深奥的。哦，有一个，我想它叫《与恶魔的战斗》（Battle with Evil），但Evil是一个缩写词 E-V-I-L，或者叫《与邪恶的约会》（Date with Evil）。它基本上是一个技术官僚式的未来，
I've been a big fan. I been really you know geeking out on that very cool i've never gotten into these i always wanted to but i always feel like a unresistable urge to just cheat my stats or like to get a role that i wanted and and then just i don't know well this kind of fixes it by adding achievements so you can they actually have three ways of playing first way you could just cheat so basically uh you can go to any page you want you can make every roll to be whatever you want it to be there's a second mode where you basically have a rewind button and um you have x number of rewinds and you can get achievements in that mode and then there's the hardcore mode the thing about the thing about these books is i do feel like you don't want to get you know three hours in the book and that's
每个人都有疯狂的身体改造之类的东西。我太爱了。不管怎样，有了这款应用，你可以去购买所有这些老书。我想每本书大概只要一两美元。应用本身自带一本免费的。我最近真的迷上了它。这简直太好玩了。我也带着我的孩子一起玩。你知道，根据书的不同，有些书可能更适合年龄稍大的孩子。有一本叫什么“来自地狱的某某”，地狱生物之类的。挺邪门儿的。我觉得那本书会给我其中一个孩子留下心理阴影。你得自己判断，你愿不愿意在孩子看完书的第二天晚上陪他一整夜不能睡。
like do you go right or left i go right you die you know or something like that like you need a rewind button otherwise it's just hard to use your time efficiently right and you can play with rewind and get uh achievements and that kind of keeps you motivated to play honestly, semi honestly. Or exploratorily, I guess. Yeah. Yeah, right. Very cool.
我一直是它的超级粉丝。我真的对这个超级着迷。太酷了。我从来没玩过这些。我一直想玩，但我总是有一种不可抗拒的冲动，想要在数据上作弊，或者掷出我想要的骰子，然后……不知道为什么，这款应用通过加入成就系统解决了一这个问题。它们实际上有三种游戏方式。第一种方式是你可以直接作弊。基本上，你可以去你想去的任何页面，你可以让每一次掷骰子都随心所欲。第二种方式是，你基本上有一个倒带按钮，而且你有一定次数的倒带机会，在这种模式下你可以获得成就。然后还有硬核模式。关于这些书的一点是，我觉得你不会想在读了三小时后，
My book of the show is not related. It is Evolutions in Bread, Artisan Panbread and Dutch Oven Loaves at Home. Nice. Which is a mouthful by Ken Forkish. I've talked about his, well, I don't know if it's his first book, but another book he has,
遇到“你是向右走还是向左走？我向右走，然后你死了”或者类似的情况。就像你需要一个倒带按钮，否则很难高效利用你的时间，对吧？你可以开着倒带功能玩并获得成就，这能让你保持玩下去的动力，半诚实地玩，或者说以探索的方式玩，我猜是这样。对，对。太酷了。
which is flour, water, salt, yeast. I don't know, for whatever reason, I got it in my head that like, I wanted to do like cook some bread, pastry, something like once a week. Just to like develop improvement at it. Cause I was always like kind of messing around with it and it just never kind of went anywhere cause I didn't do it often enough so i always forgot what i knew
我本期推荐的书和这个无关。它是《面包的演变：家庭手工パン面包与荷兰锅面包》（Evolutions in Bread: Artisan Pan Bread and Dutch Oven Loaves at Home）。
before and people like i'll keep a journal i'm terrible at doing that like i don't know so my solution was i just keep doing it and you know making sure that you know i do it often enough that i sort of keep it in my i was gonna say how often do you do this like now i try to do i've been trying to do some sort of like low yeast risen thing. So either a bread or like a pastry or something once a week. So nice. Just probably very terrible for my like, you know,
真是一本由肯·福尔基什（Ken Forkish）撰写的绕口令一般的书。我之前说过他的……好吧，我不知道这算不算他的第一本书，但他还有另一本书，
distribution of nutritional value, eating a lot of carbohydrates. But, but it is what it is. But I attempt various things. The original flour, water, salt, yeast, and like this sort of movement and sourdough had always been to do these um but but it is what it is um but i attempt various things the original flower water salt yeast and like the sort of movement in sourdough had always been to do these like free form i guess they call i don't know how to say that we're bulls b-o-u-l-e like these oh yeah where
叫《面粉、水、盐、酵母》（Flour Water Salt Yeast）。我不知道为什么，我脑子里突然冒出一个想法：我想每周烤一次面包、点心之类的东西。就为了提升和改进我的手艺。因为我以前总是瞎折腾，但从没有坚持下去，因为我做的不够频繁，所以我总是忘记我之前学到的东西。
it's like just like a dome circle right or maybe uh um like slightly an oval and this was like you know you you kind of put them in the pan, but you don't give them any support. They just sit on like a hot stone or in a Dutch oven, which is like basically like a cast iron pot with a lid to kind of keep in the steam. But this is actually very difficult because it just, if you don't do a good job,
别人会说“我会记日记”，但我做这个可太差劲了——我不知道。所以我的解决方案就是：我一直坚持做，确保我做的频率足够高，这样我才能把手艺记在……我刚想说你现在多久做一次这个？现在我尽量去做。我最近一直在尝试做一些低酵母发酵的东西。所以基本上是一周做一次面包、点心之类的。太棒了。这对于我的营养摄入结构来说可能非常糟糕，吃了很多碳水化合物。但事实就是如此。不过我会尝试各种不同的东西。原本的《面粉、水、盐、酵母》以及酸面包的这股风潮，一直是做那种自由形状的——我不知道怎么发音那个词，圆面包（boule），b-o-u-l-e，就像这种……哦，对，就是
it just like spreads out and becomes more like a pancake than a beautiful, like tall loaf of bread. And so anyways, this new book, Evolution of Bread is sort of talking about Ken sort of points out he's sort of like evolving his how he's thinking about this easiness. And who does he need to prove this to? Like, what is what is the point of doing that? It is like a pinnacle if you're trying to show your like artisanal abilities and that you are very competent and able to handle everything that's needed to go exactly right to generate one of these loaves
那种像一个小圆穹顶的面包，对吧？或者可能是一个稍微有点椭圆形的。这种做法是，你把它们放进烤盘里，但你不给它们任何支撑。它们只是放在热石上或者荷兰锅里，基本上就是一个带盖子的铸铁锅，用来锁住蒸汽。但实际上这非常困难，因为如果你没做好，
it is an achievement but if you're ultimately just trying to like have a tasty loaf of bread if you put it in a pan you get support so the window of like technique that allows you to get into a nice edible loaf of bread when you're sticking it in a loaf pan is actually like it's a much bigger target that you're aiming for than what's required to do one of these sort of like free form unbounded loaves so long-winded way to say like if you're at all like thinking about making bread and you sort of the whole pandemic thing was like everyone make a sourdough starter because you couldn't buy yeast and like make these beautiful loaves and people boasting this is my first time i ever made bread and it's just yeah that wasn't me and i actually
它就会摊开，与其说是个漂亮的高面包，不如说更像是个煎饼。所以不管怎样，这本新书《面包的演变》探讨的是肯对这种轻松度想法的演变。他需要向谁证明这一点呢？这样做到底有什么意义？如果你试图展示你的手工技艺，展示你非常熟练且能够掌控所有需要完美进行的环节来烤出一个这样的面包，那它确实算是一个成就。但如果你最终的目的只是为了吃一个美味的面包，如果你把它放进烤盘里，它就有了支撑。所以，当你把面团放进吐司盒时，能够烤出一个完美可食用面包的技术容错率，
even though i was doing it routinely i still failed quite often and it was somewhat frustrating wait so when you fail is it like you said like a pancake is that the most common way that it fails so i mean it can fail for a lot of reasons um if you're trying to do like a self-cultured sourdough there's a lot more ways for it to fail because you don't know i wasn't getting familiar with my sourdough culture you don't add commercial yeast commercial yeast is very standardized so if you know the temperature of your house you pretty much know like when to expect like the bread to be ready to bake and how much gas the yeast has made is a very important factor to success there's a very narrow window from under proofed to over proof if you miss the window entirely you end up
其实要比烤出那些自由形状、不受约束的面包所要求的技术范围大得多。所以这兜了一个大圈子想说的是：如果你哪怕有一点点想要自己做面包的想法——整个疫情期间的现象就是每个人都去做酸面包酵头，因为买不到酵母，然后烤出这些漂亮的麵包，人们还在炫耀“这是我第一次做面包”——好吧，那可不是我。事实上，尽管我经常做，我还是经常失败，这多多少少有点令人沮丧。等等，所以当你失败的时候，是不是就像你刚才说的像个煎饼？这是最常见的失败方式吗？所以，我的意思是，失败的原因有很多。如果你试图做一个天然的酸面包酵头，失败的方式就更多了，因为你并不了解它。我当时并不熟悉我的酸面包酵头，你没有添加商业酵母。商业酵母非常标准化，所以如果你知道你屋里的温度，你基本上就知道什么时候该烤面包了，酵母产生了多少气体是成功的关键因素。从发酵不足到发酵过度，中间只有非常窄的一个时间窗口。如果你完全错过了这个窗口，你最后得到的
with like something that doesn't really look very good and if you end up on either range it's just not perfect and getting it exactly right is how you sort of get the perfect one but with the sourdough culture depending on when you most recently fed it what the distribution of like bacteria to yeast is in the culture like exactly how you did it there's like many more variables and so yeah when it fails you typically in my experience you either end up with like a sloppy mess that just like doesn't really rise and isn't really bread-like. Or you end up, it's sort of ripe, but it expands. And so instead of staying tight and getting tall, where you get like a fluffy loaf, it sort of collapses down and you get a denser, like, you know, very flat loaf. What do you do when you mess up?
就是一个看起来不太好的东西。如果你落在这个范围的任意一端，它就不完美了。而要做到完全精准，正是你如何做出完美面包的方法。但对于酸面包酵头来说，取决于你最近一次喂养它的时间、酵头中细菌与酵母的比例、以及你具体是怎么操作的，这里面有更多的变量。所以，是的，当它失败时，根据我的经验，你最终要么得到一堆黏糊糊的东西，它根本发不起来，也不太像面包；要么它差不多发酵好了，但它膨胀过度了。所以它没有保持紧致并向上长成松软的面包，而是向下塌陷了，变成了一个更稠密、非常扁平的面包。当你搞砸了的时候，你会怎么做？
Do you feed that to the ducks? Like, is it safe? Do you still eat it? No, it's totally safe to to eat there's nothing wrong in it okay it's completely edible and in fact actually like right out of the oven if you've never had it before even like the mistakes are still very good oh okay they're warm and it has the beautiful bread smell i mean if you burn it it's kind of ruined but if you just like i still cook them even when i know that they've gone wrong and i still eat them um and my family will eat them as well uh but after sort of the couple hour window after making it they typically it's not something you would sort of
你会把那个喂鸭子吗？这安全吗？你还会吃它吗？不，吃起来完全安全，里面没有任何问题。好吧，它是完全可以食用的。事实上，刚出炉的时候，如果你以前没吃过，哪怕是失败的作品其实也非常好吃。哦，好吧，它们热乎乎的，而且有美妙的面包香味。我的意思是，如果你把它烤焦了，那就彻底毁了；但如果你只是……即使我知道它们做失败了，我还是会把它们烤熟然后吃掉。我家里人也会吃。但在刚做出来的几个小时窗口期之后，它通常就不是那种你还想继续吃的东西了。所以就像你说的，我们会把它切片烤成面包丁（croutons），或者你可以像你说的喂鸭子。你其实不需要把它扔掉。嗯，那，那太棒了。这本书，书里建议也可以考虑我尝试过的方法。如果我现在知道它失败了，我会把它刮下来放进一个烤盘里烘烤。当它进入吐司盒时，它有了支撑，所以它会发起来，而且往往比放任不管更接近或更有用——虽然不如正常放入烤盘的面包好，但比另一种情况要好得多。是的，有道理。所以如果你去杂货店买一条面包，它们看起来都长得差不多，它们肯定是用烤盘烤的，对吧？因为它们看起来太整齐划一了。
want to eat anymore so like you said we get we'll toast it up for croutons or you know you can kind of do like you said you can feed it to the ducks. You don't need to throw it away. Um, yeah, that is, that is awesome. The book, book, book advises potentially considering what I have tried as well. If I know it's a failure now, I'll sort of scrape it and put it in a pan and bake it. And the chances when it goes into a loaf pan, it's got support. So it'll rise and it's, uh, tends to be closer or more useful than not as good as like a properly done one into a pan, but like a lot better than the alternative. Yeah, makes sense. So like if you were to go to the grocery store and get a loaf of bread where they all kind of look the same, they definitely use pans, right? Because they look so uniform.
它们有时会卖这种圆面包。但如果你去面包过道而不是去面包店，是的，那些全都是用烤盘烤出来的。是的，明白了。好吧，这说得通。太酷了，伙计。
They sometimes will sell like these sort of round ones. But yeah, if you get like the go to the bread aisle not to a bakery yeah those are all in pans yeah got it okay that makes sense cool man um so if you are interested in making bread uh check out our link on the show notes if you use our link to buy any of these books on any of the episodes you know that helps out the show allows us to reach more people um if you whether you do that or not if you also want to support the show you can follow us on patreon so that's patreon.com programming throwdown uh we really appreciate all the patrons out there who uh you know kind of continue to support the show help out with all the hosting costs help us
所以，如果你对制作面包感兴趣，请查看我们节目笔记中的链接。如果你使用我们的链接在任何一期节目中购买这些书籍，你知道，这会对节目有所帮助，能让我们接触到更多人。无论你是否这样做，如果你还想支持节目，你可以在Patreon上关注我们，网址是 patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。我们非常感激所有在Patreon上支持节目的赞助者，你们（你知道的）继续支持节目，帮助我们分摊所有的托管成本，帮助我们接触到新听众以及所有这些好东西。
reach new people and all that good stuff and And with that, it is time for tool of the show. My tool of the show is Jinja. Have you ever used Jinja, Patrick? Once. Once, okay. Enough to know what it is. Cool, yeah, Jinja is really interesting. So the way that a lot of people know about, you know, templating is through
好了，接下来是本期推荐工具时间。我本期推荐的工具是Jinja。你用过Jinja吗，帕特里克？用过一次。用过一次，好吧。对其有所了解。酷，是的，Jinja真的非常有趣。所以，很多人了解模板引擎的方式是通过
PHP. So, you know, people have done PHP where you're writing some HTML and then you maybe want a button that is red if the person's credit card is expired and it's gray if the credit card isn't expired. And so you're going through writing and then all of a sudden you do like, I forgot what is in PHP. I think it's like open bracket question mark PHP. And you can write some if statements and then you can emit different colors depending on some logic in your program. But then all of that is in your HTML file or maybe your.php file, you know, has like a bunch of things you want to output, a bunch of text or content you want to output. But then also has some logic.
PHP。所以，你知道，人们用过PHP，你在其中编写一些HTML，然后你可能想要一个按钮：如果用户的信用卡过期了，它就是红色的；如果信用卡没过期，它就是灰色的。所以你一路写下来，然后突然之间你写了……我忘了PHP里是怎么写的了。我想大概是开括号问号PHP。你可以写一些if语句，然后根据你程序中的某种逻辑来输出不同的颜色。但所有这些都写在你的HTML文件里，或者说你的.php文件里，你知道的，里面有一堆你想输出的东西、一堆你想输出的文本或内容。但它同时也包含一些逻辑。
And that logic is sort of describing a whole bunch of different outcomes. Like a choose your own adventure book. And so then what happens is you pass it through some type of templating engine. And so it will replace all of that logic with whatever answer it comes to. And so you end up with just a pure HTML file at the end. There's no reason why this only has to be a PHP thing or HTML thing. You can just, anytime you're emitting any text, you can emit, like you could create something that has, you know, logic built into the actual text. And then you just have to wrap it in this sort of templating command, which will, you know, you give that command the text, which has the logic in it. And then you give it the context so you know the variables that you know you expect it to be using and then what it will return is you know the final text with all the templates resolved and so there's actually a lot of places where um you know either you're sending text to somebody you're rendering rendering text on a website, even if you're building a command line app at the moment. And so the command line app is writing a lot of text to
而这些逻辑在某种程度上描述了各种不同的结果。就像一本“选择你自己的冒险”的书。所以接下来发生的事情是，你把代码通过某种模板引擎运行一遍。它会将所有的逻辑替换为你所期望的任何结果。所以最后你得到的就是一个纯粹的HTML文件。没有理由说这只能是PHP的事情或HTML的事情。随时随地，当你输出任何文本时，你都可以输出……比如你可以创建一些在实际文本中内置了逻辑的东西。然后你只需要把它包裹在这个模板命令中，你把带有逻辑的文本交给这个命令，然后你提供上下文，这样你就知道你期望它使用的变量是什么，然后它返回的将是……你知道的，模板全部解析完成后的最终文本。所以实际上有很多场景下，你知道的——要么你正在向某人发送文本，要么在网站上渲染文本，甚至如果你此时正在构建一个命令行应用程序，
the console. You could put all of this logic in Python or C++ or whatever language, but it starts to become really cumbersome because now you have sort of this disconnect where you have, you know, a lot of your content sitting in one file, but then you have all these, you know, rules to manipulate it in the other in somewhere else. And, you know, templating and I found Jinja to be really quite nice. I used a combination of Jinja and afterwards I did a Regex, kind of a post-processing step. And between the two of them, it actually produced a pretty beautiful kind of environment to make content. So yeah, if you've never used a templating engineer, if you don't know what that is, take some time to go through the Jinja docs, understand what it does. There's a really great documentation that has a lot of examples. And it might be sort of like a whole aircraft.
而这个命令行应用程序正在向控制台写入大量文本。你可以把所有这些逻辑写在Python、C++或任何语言中，但它开始变得非常笨重，因为现在你面临某种割裂感：你的很多内容存放在一个文件中，而所有用于操作这些内容的规则却在别处的某个地方。而且，模板引擎——我发现Jinja确实相当不错。我结合使用了Jinja，之后还使用正则表达式（Regex）做了一个后处理步骤。这两者结合起来，实际上为制作内容创造了一个相当精美的环境。所以，是的，如果你从来没有使用过模板引擎，或者如果你不知道那是什么，花点时间通读一下Jinja的文档，了解它的功能。它的文档非常棒，里面有很多例子。这可能就像是一个……
There's actually, I think, a place for these kind of things in most apps. I think, as you mentioned, it can be really useful to separate out. People have that, hey, I want to make a report. Maybe it's as an HTML page or a LaTeX and you're going to make, you know, compile it to something else or whatever that, you know, hey, I'm going to just emit the like markdown from my, you know, all the outputters standard to the file stream, you know, the stream out, stream operator out. But then you end up with this like nasty coupling, like your code doesn't really want the data to live in it like that. It's just it's sort of ugly. It doesn't it doesn't work that well. So what I've been able to do, yeah, like, like you're mentioning is sort of say, hey, I want to make a weekly report. And I keep just writing the same thing over and over again. So I want something that says, you know, put the date here, and I'm going to make an image. And I just want the file path where I make the image to go here. And then you run it through. And it's a time saving, it separates it out. And depending on how much of that style task you do, it could be a huge game changer. Yeah, totally. I wonder if there's some type of plugin for Google Docs, where you can write kind of like macros that you know have jinja templates in them there's got to be something like that i'm sure i feel like i've never used customer relationship management crm tooling but i feel like a lot of crm tooling
其实我觉得，在大多数应用中这类东西都有其用武之地。正如你所提到的，把它独立出来真的非常有用。人们会说：“嘿，我想生成一份报告。”可能是一个 HTML 页面，或者是一个 LaTeX 文件，你要把它编译成其他格式，或者诸如此类的事情。你知道的，嘿，我只想从我的所有标准输出器中把 Markdown 输出到文件流，也就是流式输出、流运算符输出。但最终你会得到这种糟糕的耦合，你的代码其实并不希望数据那样存在里面。这简直，可以说是有点丑陋。它，它不是那么好用。所以，我所能做到的，是的，就像，就像你提到的那样，可以说：“嘿，我想制作一份周报。”而我一直在重复写相同的内容。所以，我需要这样一个东西：它说，你知道的，把日期放在这里，我要制作一张图片。我只想要生成图片的那个文件路径放在这里。然后你运行它。这既节省了时间，又做到了分离。根据你做这种风格的任务有多少，这可能会带来颠覆性的改变。是的，完全同意。我想知道有没有那种针对 Google Docs 的插件，你可以在里面写类似宏的东西，里面包含 Jinja 模板。肯定有类似的东西，我确信。我感觉我从来没用过客户关系管理（CRM）工具，但我感觉很多 CRM 工具
also supports these kinds of templating because that's how you get those like personalized spam emails right like yeah hey it's been 73 days since you know we last contacted you and you bought this thing and your name is this and like it's like i this is that's how those are all done i assume yep yep that makes sense have you ever gotten uh have you ever seen something where there is an error in the crm tool and you got someone else's stuff no i've seen ones where they didn't like replace out whatever macro. Oh yeah, that's a good one too. You bought on date and it's like, oh, oops.
也支持这种模板，因为这就是你获取那些个性化垃圾邮件的方式，对吧？就像，嘿，距离我们上次联系你已经过去 73 天了，你买了这件东西，你的名字是这个，然后像，就好像，我是说，所有这些都是这么做出来的，我猜。没错，没错，这说得通。你有没有收到过……呃，你有没有见过这样的情况：CRM 工具里出了个错误，然后你收到了别人的东西？不，我见过那种没有替换掉某个宏的。哦，对，那个也不错。你购买于“括号 括号 日期”，然后就会觉得，哦，糟糕。
You bought on bracket, bracket date. No, there was an issue where Uber was trying to solicit like former Googlers and they were sending kind of blanket emails to basically anybody they knew who worked at Google in the past, but there was an off by one error. And so I got an email and it was like, hello, like Jonah Grossberg, uh, you know, uh, like, well, you should come to Uber. Like we 4X last year or whatever. I was part of this like ex Googlers kind of like LinkedIn group, or I think I'm'm still in there somewhere.
你购买于“括号 括号 日期”。不，曾有过这样一个问题：Uber 试图拉拢前谷歌员工，他们向基本上他们认识的过去在谷歌工作过的任何人发送群发邮件，但里面出现了一个“差一错误”（off-by-one error）。所以我收到了一封邮件，上面写着：“你好，就像乔纳·格罗斯伯格（Jonah Grossberg），呃，你知道的，呃，就像，嗯，你应该来 Uber。就像我们去年实现了 4 倍增长还是怎么的。”我曾是这个类似前谷歌员工的 LinkedIn 群组的成员，或者我想我大概还在里面的某个地方。
And yeah, someone posted and they're like, hey, you know, I got an email from Uber for someone else's name. And yeah, it turns out they sent like thousands of those. Yeah, I don't know what the line is between the like mass marketing emails, the like CRM individuals and like these kind of middle ground,
然后，是的，有人发帖说：“嘿，你知道的，我收到了 Uber 发来的一封带有别人名字的邮件。”然后，是的，结果证明他们发了数千封这样的邮件。是的，我不知道大规模营销邮件、CRM 个人邮件以及这种中间地带之间的界限在哪里，
like blanket things. I don't, that ecosystem, I understand what the tools are and where they live kind of thing, like blanket things i don't that ecosystem i understand what the tools are and where they live kind of thing but i don't actually know i'm not very familiar with the space i think that there's a huge opportunity here for i mean think about like all the communication that you do that is very regular i think that you know i almost wonder if we need like a crm for you know normal people like like something that doesn't require so much ramp up they have one i think it's called julia crm oh yeah no that's not it there is one that's like a
比如群发邮件。我不知道，那个生态系统，我理解这些工具是什么以及它们存在于哪里，诸如此类。但实际上我并不清楚，我对这个领域不是很熟悉。我认为这里有一个巨大的机会——我是说，想想你所做的所有那些非常规律的交流。我认为，你知道的，我甚至在想，我们是否需要一个面向（你知道的）普通人的 CRM？就像那种不需要那么多上手准备的东西。他们有一个，我想它叫朱莉娅 CRM（Julia CRM）。哦，不对，不是那个。有一个是这样的：
crm for for like your home life right right i always like intrigued i have it on my list somewhere oh no this okay we'll have to look at it but yeah i think that there is an opportunity there but yeah that's my tool of the show if you don't if you've never used templating in your in your stuff definitely check this out learn about it it's a good skill to have oh monica ah that's it oh all right good i found it i don't feel so bad monica open source personal crm helps organize your social interactions with your loved ones. Wow. Interesting. So I think, yeah, you give it your contacts. You sort of say when you've talked to people how often you'd want to talk to them, that kind of stuff. Wow. This is fascinating. Okay. All right. I don't have a review for it. So maybe next time we can make it our tool of the
一个针对你家庭生活的 CRM，对吧？对，我总是很好奇，我的列表里某处记着这个。哦，不对，好吧，我们得查查看。但，是的，我认为这里有个机会。不过，这就是我本期推荐的工具。如果你从未在你的东西里用过模板，一定要去看看这个，了解一下，这是一个很好的技能。哦，莫妮卡（Monica），啊，就是这个！哦，好吧，太好了，我找到了。我没觉得那么糟。莫妮卡，一个开源的个人 CRM，帮助你组织与挚爱之人的社交互动。哇，有趣。所以我觉得，是的，你把联系人输入进去。你可以设定你和人们谈话的频率、你希望多久和他们聊一次，诸如此类的事情。哇，这太迷人了。好吧。好吧，我没有关于它的评价。所以也许下次我们可以把它作为我们本期的
show. Yeah. We'll have to do a bit of research on this. All right. My tool of the show yeah we'll have to we'll have to do a bit of research on this all right my tool of the show is real r-i-l-l which is a little difficult to google so it's real data.com r-i-l-l data.com and it's sort of tagline is radically simple metrics dashboards but it feeds right into what we were talking about. I believe actually a default like backend it wants to use is DuckDB, which is why I was like laughing. It is a local dashboard you can run. You can sort of start it up. You can Jupyter Notebook. You run the tool, it opens a website, and then you can sort of add in a CSV file. You can point it at a SQLite database. You can point it out a Postgres database if you have one. And what it does is it kind of does those things you automatically want to do. Like if you had a CSV file that was like, for me, it's always like, oh, how many of this type of thing?
推荐工具。是的，我们得对这个做点研究。好吧，我本期的推荐工具是 Rill，拼写是 R-I-L-L，这个名字在谷歌上不太好搜，所以网址是 realdata.com，也就是 r-i-l-l-data.com。它的标语大概是“极其简单的指标仪表盘”，但这完全契合我们刚才讨论的内容。其实我猜它默认想使用的一个后端是 DuckDB，这就是我刚才笑的原因。这是一个你可以在本地运行的仪表盘。你可以启动它。你可以用 Jupyter Notebook。你运行这个工具，它会打开一个网页，然后你就可以导入一个 CSV 文件。你可以把它指向一个 SQLite 数据库。如果你有的的话，也可以指向一个 Postgres 数据库。它所做的事情，就是自动帮你完成那些你本就想做的事情。比如，如果你有一个 CSV 文件，对我和我而言总是这样：“哦，这种东西有多少？”
How many of that type of thing where I have some string that is an enum or whatever? And it'll give you the sort of like breakdown, like this percentage, that percentage. It lets you sort of explore your data. If you have timestamps, it sort of understands timestamps and can show you things over time and bucketed. You can also give it models, which is like how to extract the kind of thing in a SQL query for what you want. You can have dashboards where you sort of write SQL queries against it. And it's just a really quick way to like point it out a CSV and sort of have it pretend or set of CSVs and how to sort of join across them and have it it's more on this sort of like streaming log of data, just dumping out and you're sort of aggregating and doing analysis.
那种东西有多少？我有一些字符串是枚举（enum）或其他什么。它会给出各种明细，比如这个百分比、那个百分比。它让你能够探索自己的数据。如果你有时间戳，它能理解时间戳，并能按时间展示各种数据、进行分桶（bucket）。你还可以给它提供模型，也就是如何在 SQL 查询中提取你想要的东西。你可以通过编写针对它的 SQL 查询来制作仪表盘。这是一种非常快捷的方式，只需指定一个 CSV 文件，或者一组 CSV 文件，以及如何在它们之间进行连接（join），它就会处理这些数据。这更偏向于那种流式日志数据，直接倾倒出来，然后由你来进行聚合和分析。
And there's sort of this distinction arriving between the two approaches. And there's a lot of trade-offs here. I think DuckDB is read only. And so because of that, they could do a whole bunch of optimizations. Okay. Yeah. So it's sort of like, you're not meant to be doing the like CRUD stuff, right? And just sort of like going in and manipulating single, it's just sort of like, you just keep appending to it and it's keeping in log. But I think that's an entirely sort of
这两种方法之间正逐渐产生一种区分。这里面有很多权衡。我认为 DuckDB 是只读的。正因如此，他们可以做出一整套优化。好吧。是的，所以它有点像，你不是去搞那些 CRUD（增删改查）的东西，对吧？不是那种进去操作单个数据的事情，它只是，你不断地往里面追加（append），它就一直保存在日志里。但我觉得这完全是一种
like powerful thing to do. And like we were mentioning, not being afraid of SQL, I think putting a bunch of stuff in a SQL dashboard and allowing you to write queries on it rather than... I find myself often trying to do things in Excel with CSVs and not very powerful Excel either. And it's not really the right tool for the job. So there's like a set of tools in the tool belt that exists in this space that I know I'm personally weak on. This is amazing. What is the dashboarding like? You can create like time series and pie charts and all of that is it pretty good yeah i mean if you sort of look it's going to be hard to do over an audio podcast right if you sort of look at their in the documents and sort of look at the developer
非常强大的做法。就像我们刚才提到的，不要害怕 SQL。我认为把一堆东西放进 SQL 仪表盘里，允许你在上面编写查询，而不是……我发现自己经常试图用 Excel 处理 CSV 文件，而且用的还不是功能很强大的 Excel。这其实并不是干这个的正确工具。所以，在这个领域存在着一套工具箱，我知道我自己在这方面比较弱。这太惊人了。仪表盘长什么样？你可以创建时间序列、饼图，所有这些都有吗？效果挺不错吗？是的，我的意思是，如果你去看的话——在一个音频播客里很难展示——如果你去看他们的文档，看他们的开发者
documents they have some pictures of the kinds of uh dashboards they do i don't think it's as big as you might get from something like a, you know, production dashboarding company, right? Like Tableau or something. But I think it's in the same, but yeah, exactly. Yeah.
文档，他们有一些他们制作的各种仪表盘的照片。我觉得它可能没有像那种成熟的、生产环境级别的仪表盘公司（比如 Tableau 之类的）做得那么宏大。但我觉得它处在同一个，不过，是的，完全正确。是的。
This is really, really cool. Yeah. Folks should definitely check this out. This is awesome. Oh yeah. I see that backed by duck DB and Druid. Yeah.
这真的是太酷了。是的，大家一定要去看看这个。这太棒了。哦，是的，我看到它是由 DuckDB 和 Druid 支持的。是的，
Very cool. Yeah. This is a winner for sure. I'm actually going to try this today. All right. I scored one. Yes yes one jason hasn't tried yet and it wasn't a video game i wonder like how yeah gosh so many tools of the show have become just permanent parts of my workflow now i think i feel like that's uh for us uh you know for us i think that's the uh personally like the part of the content of the show that i gets that I get the most out of. You have some amazing tools over the past like 10 years or so.
非常酷。是的，这绝对是个赢家。我今天就要去试试这个。好吧，我得了一分。耶，耶，有一款杰森还没试过，而且还不是电子游戏。我在想，天哪，有多少期节目的推荐工具现在已经成了我工作流中不可或缺的一部分。我觉得，对我们来说，你知道的，对我们而言，我觉得这——就个人而言——是节目内容中我收获最大的部分。在过去大概 10 年里，你们推荐过一些非常惊艳的工具。
That's what you got to get auto GPT to do is like get a task list, which is like go through and extract just the tools of the show, just the book of the show, just whatever into like mini podcast channels. Yeah, that's so true. Yeah, we should have or just I thought you were going to say a Google sheet. It'd be awesome if GPT could scrape programmingthrowdown.com and put all the tools. If you do this. No, no, but people want to listen to our rendition about why it's such an amazing. Oh yeah. Even better would be if it put the MP3 timestamp or something, like some deep link into the MP3.
你得让 Auto-GPT 去做的就是：获取一个任务列表，比如遍历并仅仅把每期节目的工具、每期节目的书、或者其他任何东西提取到迷你的播客频道里。是的，太对了。是的，我们应该有一个，或者我刚才以为你要说的是一个 Google 表格。如果 GPT 能够抓取 programmingthrowdown.com 并把所有工具都列出来，那就太棒了。如果你这么做的话。不，不，但人们想听我们畅谈为什么这个工具如此惊艳。哦，是的。甚至更好的是，如果它能加上 MP3 的时间戳什么的，比如对 MP3 的深度链接。
I don't know if that's even a thing. Okay. All right. timestamp or something like some some deep link into the mp3 i don't know if that's even a thing okay all right let's jump into position localization yeah take it away yeah so you know i'll kick this off by saying that i neither jason or i as a disclaimer we always give or or mostly give neither of us are experts in this but i think we've both been around it a little bit and familiar so So just want to a bit like set up the problem, and then introduce some of the kind of like terms and kind of things you'll hear. I apologize in advance, you may want to tune out if this is like the thing you do all the time. You may find some of this offensive, the same thing we give for some of our more impassioned Lisp programming languages that we talk about but
我不知道这是否真的行得通。好吧。好吧，时间戳什么的，或者对 MP3 的某个深度链接，我不知道这是否真的行得通。好吧，好吧，让我们切入正题：定位（Localization）。是的，开始吧！好的，那么（你知道的）我先开个场，声明一下杰森和我——我们总是会这么声明，或者大多数时候会声明——我们都不是这方面的专家，但我认为我们俩都接触过一点，也算熟悉。所以，我们只是想稍微铺垫一下这个问题，然后介绍一些你们会听到的术语和相关概念。提前道个歉，如果这是你天天都在做的事情，你可能想直接跳过。你可能会觉得其中某些内容冒犯到了你，就像我们谈论那些更让人充满热情的 Lisp 编程语言时一样，不过
one of the things that isn't always obvious to people is uh how do you just like figure out where you are like we have this you know as humans i guess kind of understanding of where you are when we start talking about a phone let's just talk about a phone like how does the phone know where it is and i think people probably mostly but we'll go over it say oh it's just using gps right so we have these satellites up in orbit um roughly the satellites know where they are very precisely because it turns out like orbits are something that math can predict really well when there's not you know air friction and we sort of know how they change over time and where they are so you can kind of
有一件事对大家来说并不总是显而易见，那就是：呃，你究竟是怎么弄清楚自己在哪里的？我们作为人类，大概有一种关于自己身处何地的理解。当我们开始讨论手机时，我们只谈手机——手机是怎么知道它在哪里的呢？我想大家可能大多会说，但我们还是会回顾一下，说“哦，它只是在用 GPS，对吧？”所以我们在轨道上有这些卫星。大致上，卫星非常精准地知道它们在哪里，因为事实证明，当没有空气摩擦时，数学能够非常准确地预测轨道，而且我们大致知道它们随时间如何变化、它们在哪里。所以你可以
download basically a description of all the gps satellites and like what their orbital parameters are and sort of understand kind of what you would expect these things are are somewhat knowable and without getting into the details of how a gps receiver works it basically listens to the radio signals coming down from all the gps and by knowing the figuring out the exact time it is with atomic clocks and knowing this orbital data, correcting for some things and listening to a bunch. You have an understanding of how far your phone is from each of the satellites. And knowing how far your phone is, the GPS receiver is, the antenna is from each of the satellites. You can run this solution to figure out where you think you are and the more satellites you have the more refined you can get and this normally gets you you know and if you're in the middle of a you know
下载基本上所有 GPS 卫星的描述，以及它们的轨道参数是什么，并大致理解你对这些东西的预期，这些在一定程度上是可知的。不深入探讨 GPS 接收器的工作原理，它基本上就是接收来自所有 GPS 的无线电信号，通过原子钟弄清楚确切的时间，并了解这些轨道数据，校正一些偏差，然后监听一大堆信号。你就能够知道你的手机距离每颗卫星有多远。知道了你的手机——GPS 接收器，即天线——距离每颗卫星有多远之后，你就可以运行这个解算来弄清楚你认为自己在哪里。你拥有的卫星越多，定位就能越精确。这通常能让你——如果你身处一个
open prairie uh yes is going to get you down to a pretty good like couple meters you know a few yards uh kind of thing without a lot of a lot of things and there's a lot of improvements you do on getting that refined and fancier and fancier gps there's noise in the upper atmosphere and you know you can use base stations known positions to offset this is a whole thing we're not going to get into how like gps position position works those positions only really come in sort of like you know normally kind of get only once a second or maybe 10 times a second uh which you say oh it's pretty fast and you're right for like a human walking around like you know that's probably you know generally knowing where you are if you have you know if you had lost your phone and you knew where your phone was within a couple meters and you know it only updated every second you'd be able to find it yeah and so this is the most common
开阔的草原上，是的——GPS 可以把你精确到相当不错的几米范围内（几码内），不需要太多复杂的东西。为了让 GPS 变得更精确、更花哨，你可以做很多改进。高层大气中存在噪声，你可以使用已知位置的基站来抵消这些噪声。这是一个很大的课题，我们不会深入探讨 GPS 定位是如何工作的。这些定位实际上通常只有（你知道的）差不多一秒一次，或者一秒十次的频率。你会说：“哦，这挺快的。”对于一个到处走动的人来说，你说得对，（你知道的）这大概（你知道的）通常足够让你知道自己在哪里。如果你丢了手机，而你知道你的手机在几米之内，并且你知道它每秒更新一次，你就能找到它。是的，所以这是最常见的
common one you do the first problem you run into with that is okay but what if i'm inside turns out like the things that make our shelters our you know buildings our houses our malls or even like downtown and the city you start to run into a lot of complications either the gps signal is bouncing around and it's it's called multipath. It's very confusing. Or if you're inside a bomb shelter, let's say, your phone can't hear the radio signals. It can't receive.
一种方法。你遇到的第一个问题是：好吧，如果我在室内呢？事实证明，构成我们庇护所的东西——我们的建筑物、房屋、商场，甚至是闹市区和城市——你会遇到很多复杂情况。要么是 GPS 信号到处反弹，这被称为“多径效应”（multipath），非常令人迷惑；要么如果你身处防空洞内（比方说），你的手机就接收不到无线电信号了，它接收不到了。
There's not enough radio energy making it through. And so, Ben, what do you do? I have kind of maybe a dumb question on the part you already talked about. So GPS, so there's satellites that are going in orbit around the earth or maybe they're not they're in some kind of stationary no they're they're actually very low orbit so they're actually going pretty fast across the sky okay so there's there's gps satellites going fast across the sky what does your phone do to talk to like are these satellites just constantly just sending out like spheres of energy and your phone's picking up on them is that how it works yes yeah okay so they're all broadcasting uh a set message basically at a specific rate and as you pointed out from
没有足够的无线电能量穿透进来。那么，本，你该怎么办？关于你已经讲过的那部分，我有一个挺蠢的问题。所以 GPS，有卫星在环绕地球的轨道上运行，或者也许它们不是？它们是在某种静止状态吗？不，它们其实是低轨道运行，所以它们在天空中穿梭的速度其实相当快。哦，所以有 GPS 卫星在天空中快速穿梭。你的手机为了与之对话会做什么？是这些卫星只是不断地向外发送能量球，然后你的手机接收这些能量球吗？是这么运作的吗？是的，没错。哦，所以它们都在广播一组基本以特定速率发出的消息。正如你所指出的，从
radiating out from the antenna an antenna has like a specific kind of pattern for strength but basically it travels at roughly the speed of light in a bubble got it so if you're and there's no two-way communication i guess that isn't obvious but your phone doesn't talk to the gps satellites gps's are broadcast only or at least for for the intensive purposes of this conversation right only broadcasting out and they're just broadcasting out there basically it's like their metadata with the time code and this kind of stuff and they're just broad broadcasting out this kind of thing it's a very very specific pattern with some specific nuance in it that allows you to do a precise timing of understanding the two things when the satellite believes it sent the message and when you heard the message
天线辐射出来——天线有一种特定的强度模式——但基本上它在气泡中以大致光速传播。明白了。所以如果你身处其中，并且没有双向通信（我想这并不是显而易见的，但你的手机并不和 GPS 卫星对话），GPS 是“只广播”的，或者至少在本次对话的讨论范围内，它们只是向外广播，它们只是广播……基本上就像是带有时间码的元数据之类的东西，它们就在向外广播这种东西。这是一种非常非常特定的模式，其中包含一些特定的细微差别，允许你进行精确的计时，从而理解两件事：卫星认为它发送消息的时间，以及你听到消息的时间。
got it so if you know that then you know the distance to the satellite and if you heard the message. Got it. So if you know that, then you know the distance to the satellite. And if you know the satellite's orbit, then you know sort of where in the Earth frame, like the satellite was at that time. And you're trying to work backwards to where you are based on it. But giving you one, if you know, let's just say you assume you're on the ground, which isn't a good assumption. And that the Earth is the complex thing to describe but basically the earth is roughly a ball i'll just say that uh the earth is a ball and you assume you're on the surface you kind of
明白了。所以如果你知道了这一点，你就知道了到卫星的距离；如果你听到了消息，明白了。所以如果你知道了这一点，你就知道了到卫星的距离；如果你知道卫星的轨道，你就会知道在那个时刻卫星在地球坐标系中的大致位置。然后你试图根据这些信息反推你在哪里。但只给你一个，如果你知道——假设你就在地面上（这不是一个好的假设），而且地球是一个很复杂的形状（但基本上地球大致是一个球体，我姑且这么说）——地球是个球，而你假设自己身处表面，你就可以
project out that sphere so then you would kind of know where you are in a roughly circular shape right because a circle is the shape that you get when you intersect the radiating ball of a GPS satellite and the ball of the earth. I'm hand-waving a bunch there. If you had another one and you knew another distance and you intersected all three, the ball of the earth, the ball of satellite one, the ball of satellite two, you would sort of know where you are instead of on a circle, the sort of two points on the circle, where is the intersection of all three so if you imagine taking a circle and intersecting it with a sphere right because you know the distance you know sort of like what those two points could be yeah so i think it's like every time you intersect you
把那个球体投影出去。那么你就会知道你大致处于一个圆形的形状中，对吧？因为当你把 GPS 卫星辐射出的球体与地球的球体相交时，你得到的形状就是一个圆。这里我做了很多简化。如果你有另一颗卫星，并且你知道另一个距离，然后你把所有这些相交：地球的球体、卫星一的球体、卫星二的球体，你就会知道自己不在一个圆上，而是在圆上的两个点上——所有这三个球体的交集在哪里？所以如果你想象拿一个圆和一个球体相交，对吧？因为你知道距离，你知道这两个点大概可能是哪些。是的，所以我认为，就像每次相交都会
eliminate a dimension right so if you have two three-dimensional things you intersect you get a two-dimensional object in this case a circle and then when you intersect the circle with something else you get a one-dimensional object which is these two points on a line and then if you could do a third one i guess at that point you would get a single point or a fourth one whatever it is yeah yeah no no you're right except that we have to work backwards a little because that first assumption that you're on the ground and that the earth like that and that the earth's sort of surface is flat uh is actually uh horribly untrue right and so like it could be in a plane you could be on a mountain right like any of these things and so uh you actually want one additional one and so to eliminate so that you don't have to start with
消除一个维度，对吧？所以如果你有两个三维的东西相交，你会得到一个二维的对象，在这个例子中是一个圆；然后当你把这个圆和其他东西相交时，你会得到一个一维的对象，也就是一条线上的这两个点；然后如果你能做第三个，我想到了那个时候你会得到一个单点，或者第四个，无论是什么。是的，是的，不，你说的对，除了我们必须稍微反向推导，因为最初的假设——即你站在地面上，地球的表面是平的——实际上
the assumption of that you're on the center on the surface of a you know ball and so oh i see i see yeah you're right so if you don't if you don't have the earth if you didn't make a ball out of the earth like if you left that one out then then you could you make up for it just by having more satellites you could do the same thing so you start with one satellite you know you're on a sphere you know then you say the second one now you know you're on yeah so it's just you start one back. Got it. Right. Cool. And so this works incredibly well.
错得离谱，对吧？所以，你可能在一架飞机上，可能在一座山上，对吧？任何这些情况都有可能。所以你实际上需要一个额外的卫星，从而消除……这样你就不用从“你站在一个球体表面”的假设出发了。哦，我明白了，我明白了。是的，你说的对，所以如果没有地球……如果你没有把地球当成一个球体，如果你把那个假设去掉，那么你就可以仅仅通过拥有更多的卫星来弥补这一点。你可以做同样的事情：你从一颗卫星开始，你知道你在一个球体上；然后你说第二颗，现在你知道你在……是的，所以你只是往回推了一步。明白了。对，酷。所以这效果好得惊人。
There's a ton of nuance about refining. So you're eliminating the dimensions as sort of first step. And as you get more and more satellites, you sort of reduce your ambiguity, but only to a point because then there's sort of issues with listening to these signals and understanding like how precise
这里有很多关于精炼的细节。所以第一步是通过不断增加卫星来消除维度。随着你拥有的卫星越来越多，你就能降低不确定性，但这也只能达到一定程度，因为随后会出现监听这些信号以及理解以下方面的问题：
can you measure that distance? So you're not actually getting a point, you're getting sort of an uncertainty. And the uncertainty is depending on, like, for instance, if the satellite is down on the horizon, it's traveling through more atmosphere and it's more ambiguous versus if it's straight overhead, that's really good for you. And it's just like a variety of other factors that give you a sort of blob of uncertainty that's shaped in a certain way and you can do various techniques to kind of like squish it tighter and tighter so that you know
你能把那个距离测量得有多精确？所以你实际上得到的不是一个点，而是一个不确定性区域。这个不确定性取决于——比如，如果卫星在低空的水平线上，它穿过的大气层就更多，不确定性就更大；而如果它在头顶正上方，这对你就非常有利。还有各种其他因素会形成一个特定形状的不确定性团块（blob），你可以通过各种技术把它压缩得越来越紧，以便你
better where you are and none of that works as soon as you can't see the satellites so before we go into size i guess while we're on that topic we should go to one other thing people kind of know about um which works roughly in the same same way but it'll also work for indoors which is what i described works great except if you've ever used an old satellite receiver or today if um you know you use like something that doesn't have a cell phone antenna or wi-fi antenna in it for this purpose um so like i have a a little drone like a dji drone you take it outside and it takes a while to acquire satellites it sort of says acquiring satellites acquiring satellites right right i had this old garmin that did that yeah exactly and the reason why is it has to
能更清楚地知道自己在哪里。但只要你看不到卫星，所有这些就都不起作用了。所以在我们讨论室内之前——既然我们聊到了这个话题——我们应该讲讲人们了解的另一种方法。它的运作方式大致相同，但它也适用于室内。刚才我描述的方法效果极佳，除非你用过旧的卫星接收器，或者今天如果你……你知道的，用了一个没有手机天线或 Wi-Fi 天线来实现此目的的设备——
kind of receive these messages do a bunch of disambiguation and it takes a while to sort of update itself to learn the new corrections to all the orbital mechanics to kind of all this stuff has to take place and it takes a while and as And as you said earlier, if you're inside, there's... Yep. It will just never finish because it doesn't ever get a radio signal that it's just sitting there listening for. And so there's all these techniques for helping figure out where you are a lot quicker. And then you know what to listen for, you're resolving ambiguity. So one is if you have a cell phone antenna, you can do the same thing with cell phone towers. So cell phone towers are very precisely location known. They don't move around a lot, right? Because installed in a giant tower, right?
比如我有一个小无人机，大疆（DJI）无人机。你把它带到户外，它需要花上一段时间来搜星。它会显示“正在搜星，正在搜星”，对吧？我以前那台 Garmin 也是这样的，对，完全如此。原因在于它必须接收这些消息，做一大串消歧义处理，并且需要花时间更新自己，以学习所有轨道力学的最新修正值，所有这些事情都必须发生，这需要时间。正如你刚才所说，如果你在室内，就会……没错，它永远也无法完成，因为它根本接收不到它一直在静静监听的无线电信号。所以这里有很多技术，可以帮助更快地弄清楚你在哪里。然后你知道要监听什么，你就能解决歧义。第一种方法是，如果你有手机天线，你就可以对手机基站做同样的事情。手机基站的位置是非常精确已知的。它们不会到处移动，对吧？因为它们装在巨大的铁塔上，对吧？
And so you can use cell phone antenna location and relative strengths to do effectively the same thing, right? Very similar, but you're using instead of just the message and the timing, you're using signal strength to estimate how far away you are. Because the signal attenuates much quicker, it doesn't, it's not broadcasting from space, right. And then when you move inside, it turns out you can also do the same thing. But cell phone towers a little harder, they're not really inside a lot more noise. But it turns out we installed a lot of mini cell phone tower equivalents, which are Wi Fi routers. And so a long time ago, people learned, oh, okay, we can go around and most people don't move their Wi-Fi antennas around. So if you sort of understand where all the Wi-Fi, so you've, there was, I'm not going to sort of name companies,
所以你可以利用手机天线的定位和相对信号强度，来做实际上相同的事情，对吧？非常相似，但你用的不是消息和计时，而是用信号强度来估计你有多远。因为信号衰减得快得多，它不是从太空广播的，对吧。然后当你移动到室内时，事实证明你也可以做同样的事情。但手机基站有点难办，它们不在室内，而且室内噪声大得多。不过事实证明，我们安装了大量微型手机基站的替代品，也就是 Wi-Fi 路由器。所以很久以前，人们就了解到：“哦，好吧，我们可以四处走动，而且大多数人不会挪动他们的 Wi-Fi 天线。”所以，如果你大致了解所有 Wi-Fi 的位置……曾有过——我不会点名公司，
but several, some court cases and other stuff where it turned out people were recording what network name and router Mac address and stuff were coming because they were trying to understand they were taking this survey, they knew where they were, they could sort of estimate where the Wi Fi router was by looking at it over time. And then if someone else saw it later, you would basically have some database which shows you this special number router with this name is at this location. And sometimes it would be wrong because a person could have moved it in their house or turned it off. But if you have enough of them all over the place, this becomes helpful. So this along with some other stuff allows you to more or less do the same kind of thing, but inside as well, outside, and sort of an additional input.
但有几起诉讼和其他事情表明，人们一直在记录周围出现过什么网络名称、路由器 MAC 地址之类的信息。因为他们试图去了解，他们在做这项调查时，知道自己身处何地，他们可以通过长时间的观察来大致估计 Wi-Fi ROUTER 的位置。然后，如果稍后其他人看到了它，你基本上就会拥有一个数据库，显示带有这个名字的特定编号路由器位于这个位置。有时候它可能是错的，因为有人可能在家里移动了它，或者把它关掉了。但如果你到处都有足够多的这种路由器，这就变得很有用了。所以，这连同其他一些东西，或多或少能让你做类似的事情，不仅在室外，在室内也能做到，并且提供了一个额外的输入源。
Oh, that makes sense. So it's kind of like almost like a Google Maps type thing where somebody walks through a mall. And while they're walking through a mall, they're recording the signal strengths. And because they're walking like a certain pattern, they know exactly where they are. So they're like, they're giving ground truth. They're saying like, okay, these signal strengths mean I'm in Macy's. And so then when you go to Macy's, you know, you're not telling Google you're at Macy's or whoever, like you're not telling that company you're at Macy's, but because you have the same signal strength as this other person, you know, more or less, that's how it's working. Yep. And I mean, just in general to naive way, would you be like, if you know where a Wi-Fi router vaguely is, and you can see the Wi-Fi router, you kind of know where you are in sort of absolute terms, you know, approximately, right? Not close within a few hundred meters, you know, sort of where you are, because if you weren't there, you couldn't have heard that, that, you know,
哦，这说得通。所以这有点像 Google 地图那种类型的东西：有人走过商场，在商场里走动时，他们记录下了信号强度。因为他们是按某种特定模式行走的，所以他们确切地知道自己在哪里。因此，他们提供的是“地面真实数据（ground truth）”——他们说：“好的，这些信号强度意味着我在梅西百货（Macy's）。”所以当你去梅西百货时，你并没有告诉谷歌你在梅西百货，或者不管是谁——你没有告诉那家公司你在梅西百货，但因为你和另一个人有着相同的信号强度，你或多或少就知道它是这么运作的。没错。而且，总体来说，用一种比较天真的方式来看，你会觉得：如果你大致知道一个 Wi-Fi 路由器在哪里，并且你能看到这个 Wi-Fi 路由器，你在绝对意义上就大致知道自己在哪里，对吧？误差在几百米之内，你知道自己大概在哪里，因为如果你不在那里，假设 Wi-Fi 路由器不会移动的话（这里我稍微简化了一下），你就听不到那个 Wi-Fi 路由器。所以这些方法通常对于我所说的“低更新率”场景效果很不错。但现在，如果我们开始谈论——嘿，你要去跑步，或者你在交通工具里、飞机上、汽车里、滑板车上、你选择的个人交通工具上，或者是轮滑鞋上——而你不仅想了解自己身处何地，还想知道自己的姿态，比如如果你戴着手表，试图测量某人的步数，试图弄清楚手臂的姿势是如何随时间变化的。这就是你开始添加其他传感器的地方。这些传感器给你的不是绝对位置，而是相对位置。
Wi-Fi router if you assume Wi-Fi router doesn't move hand wave that a bit. So these work generally pretty good for what I would say is sort of like for these slow update rates but now if we start talking about hey you're going for a run or you're you know in a vehicle an airplane or in a car or on your scooter or your personal transit of choice uh rollerblades um and you're trying to do more than just understand where you are but you want to know how you're positioned so like if you're on a watch and you're trying to measure like someone's steps, you're trying to say like, how is the arm position, you know, changing over time? And then this is where you start to add other sensors, sensors that don't give you your absolute position. They give you a relative position.
相对位置就是：在每个时间戳，你基本上是如何移动的、你的朝向如何、或者你的加速度如何。实现这一功能的部件，我们称之为惯性测量单元（IMU）。里面有微型陀螺仪、磁力计和加速度计，这些极其微小的芯片。有一个非常吸引人的视频，其实你可以去搜来看看，我想如果我没记错的话，是 Breaking Taps 频道的。我以前没谈过这个，他专门做了一整期关于 MEMS（微机电系统）的视频。哦，对，我看过，我不知道我有没有看过那一期，但太棒了。是的，就像它们如何相对运动一样。它们实际上是这些微小的振动金属片，蚀刻在这些芯片内部。
And the relative position is just at each timestamp, how you've moved basically, how you're oriented or how you're accelerating. And the things that do that, we call those inertial measurement units, IMUs, and you have little gyroscopes and magnetometers and accelerometers and these tiny, tiny little chips that fascinating video, actually, you can go look it up, I think it's by if i recall breaking taps i've not talked about this before he does this whole thing about mems these micro electronic machines oh yeah i've seen i don't know if i've seen that one but it's amazing yeah it's like how they move relative to each other they're actually these tiny vibrating pieces of metal inside of these that are etched
或者是硅，我想它们是被蚀刻并以特定方式掺杂的。它们如何相对运动，允许你进行这些测量。虽然并非完全没有运动部件，但并非我们传统意义上认为的那种互相滑动的运动部件。手表里面只有这些小音叉似的东西在不断振动。所以这些传感器的运行速度可以快得多，
out or silicon i guess they're etched out and doped in a certain way and how they move relative to each other allows you to take these measurements with, it's not no moving parts, but not moving parts as we traditionally think about them, like things sliding over each other. There's just these little tuning forks, basically, that are vibrating around in your watch. And so those can run much faster,
几百赫兹，100 赫兹，这非常容易。所以你能获得更快的更新率。现在你大概能看出我们要走向何方了。如果你需要非常精准的定位，你就会把这两者结合起来，对吧？所以你大致知道自己的全局位置，知道自己的朝向，现在还知道自己是如何随时间变化的。所以你可以在两次来自 GPS 的位置更新之间，了解自己是如何移动的。这些记录是如何移动的？如果你进行积分——这里的积分仅仅意味着把你在多少时间里拥有多少加速度累加起来——你会知道（你对它进行了双重插值，你把它加了两次），你把这些累积起来，你得到的结果是：你获取一个位置，然后把它加起来。当你获得下一个位置时，你再次得知它。你得到的是你在这两者之间的移动方式。所以，你不仅仅是在两者之间进行插值，说“我走的是一条直线”，而是实际上可以说：“不，我走了一点弧线，或者我拐了个弯，或者我向下俯冲了，或者我跑得很快，然后开始慢下来。”
hundreds of Hertz, 100 Hertz, this is really easy. So you get a faster update rate. Now you can kind of see where we might be going. If you want a very precise positioning, you're mixing the two, right? So you know where you are kind of globally, you know how you're oriented, also now know how you're changing over time. So you can say between two positions from GPS, how did I move? How did my, you know, these recordings, how did they move? And if you do integration, but integration here just means adding up the sort of how much acceleration you had over how much time tells you, you know, you kind of double interpolate it, you add it twice, you accumulate these, and what you're getting is, you sort of take one position, and then you add it up. And then as you get the next one, you sort of know it again. And what you get is in between how you were moving. So instead of just interpolating between the two and saying, I went on a straight line, you can actually say, No, I went on a bit of an arc, or I went on a bit of a swerve, or a dip, or I went really fast, and then I'm starting to slow
这些其他东西开始结合在一起。而这就是你开始需要一点数学帮助的地方。我刚才略过了所有这些数学计算。但现在我们可以设定这样一个问题：你最终要处理很多这样的定位问题，一方面，所有这些传感器都有噪声。所以并不是说 GPS 给出的位置带有某种误差（这种不确定性），它随时间还会到处晃动。如果你坐在同一个位置，你会注意到你的小圆点在晃动。虽然现在很多系统都在极力克服这一点，但你实际报告的位置并不是静止的，即使你可能一动不动。所以，假设你有一个 IMU，你正静止不动地在室外等待，不管在等什么，
down. And these other things begin to combine. And this is where you start to get into needing a little bit of mathematical help. So I'd hand-waved over the math of getting all of those. But now we can sort of set up the problem where you end up working a lot of these kind of positioning problems that, one, these all have noise. So it's not that GPS gives you a position with some error, this uncertainty. It also moves around over time. So if you sat in one position, you'll sort of notice your dot kind of wiggles and a lot of stuff tries to combat it now but like your actual position being reported is not stationary even though you might be stationary so let's say you have an imu and you're standing still waiting you know for whatever outside you're
你作为一个测试就站在那里不动。你的 IMU 说：“嘿，他在动，她没动，我们非常静止。”但 GPS 却让我们向右移动了一米，向左移动了一米。你就会想：“嗯，这不合常理。我有反证。”所以你需要一个数学框架，来处理某些数据有点矛盾这一事实，以及我们刚才谈到的积分。但是，如果我随着时间对加速度计和 IMU 的读数进行积分来推算我的位置，然后我得到了一个新的、与推算结果不同的 GPS 读数，
just standing still as a test um your imu says hey i'm he's not moving she's not moving like we're just still. But the GPS is moving us like one meter right and one meter left. You can go, well, that's not really true. Like, I have counter evidence to this. And so you need a mathematical framework that's going to let you handle the fact that some of this stuff is a little contradictory, as well as we talked about doing this integration. But if I integrate my Accelerometer, my IMU readings over time to understand my position, and then I get a new GPS reading that's different from that,
我该如何处理？我显然没有瞬间从用加速度计估算出的位置瞬移到新的 GPS 位置（我们知道这个位置是有噪声的）。那么，我如何将所有这些平滑地结合起来，并利用它们各自的优缺点呢？这就是你开始进入该问题这一部分的许多数学框架的时候。是的，这说得通。我的意思是，你随着时间获取样本。所以每次的误差都会不同，对吧？因为它是从某种分布中抽样出来的。然后，如你所说，你遇到了所有这些相互矛盾的情况，没有什么是绝对准确的。希望它们能对齐，但你必须有某种方法来解决冲突。这不是那种
how do I handle, I clearly didn't instantaneously move from the result of my estimating using my accelerometer to the new GPS position, which we know has noise. So how do I smooth all of these together and benefit from the sort of pros and cons of each of these. And that's where you start to enter a lot of the mathematical framework of this part of the problem. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, you're getting samples over time. And so the error is going to be different each time, right? Because there's it's drawn from some distribution. And then you you're right you have all this sort of contradictory things going on where nothing nothing's going to be exactly true hopefully that they line up but but yeah you have to have some way of resolving there isn't like a
你可以直接用一个覆盖另一个的情况。它们都在贡献某种程度的证据。正是如此。所以其中有一个——我只说这几种变体，其中最核心、大家可能都听说过的就是：卡尔曼滤波（Kalman Filter）。所以当你听到卡尔曼滤波时，大多数人都听说过。它在许多其他方面也很有用，我不会展开讲，主要是因为我会讲错——比如它到底想做什么。但这就是那个工具发挥作用的地方。这个工具的作用在于理解（我不用数学词汇了，
it's not like you just overwrite one with the other they're both sort of contributing like uh some amount of evidence that's right and so the one and i'll just there's there's several here in variations but the one that is like the topic everyone has probably heard is common filter so when you hear common filter most people have heard of this it's useful for a variety of other things as well i won't get into because mainly because i'll say it wrong uh like what exactly is trying to do but this is where that tool comes into play. And the tool comes into play in understanding, I'm going to not use the mathematical words,
因为我已经能听到我认识的那些会感到沮丧的人在叹气了）。所以，如果你说：“嘿，我的 GPS 误差呈现某种分布，也就是该信号的方差。”如果你对这一点有所了解，并且对 IMU 读数中的噪声有所了解，卡尔曼滤波就是一个结构、一个框架，允许你把这些预先已知的东西加入到滤波器的构建中。然后你就会有一种机制：我得到了一个新测量值，我进行了一次更新，我根据它对下一次我在哪做出预测；我得到了一个新的更新，我的预测错了。我该如何更新我的内部状态呢？
because I am groaning already at people I know who will be upset. So if you sort of say, hey, I have a certain kind of distribution that my GPS error gives me, the variance of that signal, if you have an understanding of that, and you have an understanding of the kind of noise in your IMU readings, the common filter is a structure, a framework to allow you to take those known things in advance, add them to the construction of the filter. And then you have a sort of, I got a new measurement, I have an update, I'm making a prediction about where I'll be next time based on that, I get a new update, my have an update. I'm making a prediction about where I'll be next time based on that. I get a new update. My prediction was wrong. How do I update my internal state so
因为我已经开始为那些会生气的熟人们感到头疼了。所以，如果你某种程度上说，嘿，我的GPS误差给我提供了一种特定类型的分布，该信号的方差，如果你对此有所了解，并且你对IMU读数中的噪声类型也有所了解，卡尔曼滤波器就是一个结构、一个框架，它允许你将这些预先已知的事项加入到滤波器的构建中。然后你会有一种，我得到了一个新的测量值，我有一个更新，我根据它对下一次会在哪里做出预测，我得到了一个新的更新，我有了一个更新。我根据它对下一次会在哪里做出预测。我得到了一个新的更新。我的预测错了。我该如何更新我的内部状态以
that I'm combining between the two? So I have an error number coming in, which is a number coming in, which is noisy. I trusted a little. Okay, how do I update where I think my position is using that, you know, that number? And how much is that I update where I think my position is using that number? And how much is that different from where I thought I was going to be? Refine my internal state a bit so that over time, I'm sort of adapting to this. And you mentioned earlier sort of ground truth. The reality is you don't actually ever know the right answer. Unless you sort of after the fact, take a survey or do some very complicated something,
这就是我在两者之间结合的方式吗？所以有一个误差数字传进来，这是一个传进来的、带有噪声的数字。我稍微信任它一点。好的，我如何利用这个数字来更新我认为自己位置的估计？我利用这个数字更新位置估计的程度是多少？这与我原本认为自己会去的地方有什么不同？稍微修正一下我的内部状态，这样随着时间推移，我就会慢慢适应这一点。你刚才提到了某种真实基准。现实情况是，你实际上永远无法确切知道正确答案。除非你在事后做个调查或者搞点非常复杂的东西，
you're not really going to know. And it's also not really that important exactly where you were. So your goal isn't to get better. Your goal is to say, hey, I'm going to try to do the best I can with the information I have. And common filter and its various forms allow you to sort of do that, allow you to say, how do I do this? Predict, update, update measure understand the various
否则你真的不会知道。而且你在哪里其实也不是那么重要。所以你的目标不是变得更好。你的目标是说，嘿，我要利用现有的信息尽力做到最好。卡尔曼滤波器及其各种变体让你能够做到这一点，让你能够说，我该如何做到这一点？预测、更新、测量理解我的各种
performance of my sensors put them all in together and sort of not just do a hacky which is what i would probably have done which is like take my gps number do something take my imu number do something it's just one sort of call into a class that handles all of it right you know you're telling it in advance what it is and it's able to to kind of take care of this yeah totally i mean i think the the thing that's nice about common filters as opposed to us trying to like hand code something or using a neural network or something like that although there are now like deep ekfs and there is that's a whole separate topic but yeah um but you know common filters are you, they work off of the covariance. So if two approaches are always wrong in the same way,
传感器的性能，把它们全部放在一起，而不只是用一种打补丁的方法——那可能是我会做的事，比如拿我的GPS数字做点什么，拿我的IMU数字做点什么。它只是对一个类的某种调用，就能处理所有这些，对吧，你提前告诉它那是什么，它就能搞定这一切。是的，完全是这样。我的意思是，卡尔曼滤波器的好处在于，与我们试图手写某些代码或使用神经网络之类的方法相比——尽管现在有深度EKF，那是另一个完全不同的话题——但卡尔曼滤波器，它们基于协方差工作。因此，如果两种方法总是以相同的方式出错，
then you won't end up sort of overcompensating. Let's say your GPS and your accelerometer, they're always, I'm making this up, but they're always sort of biased to the east. Like when one has an error that's too far to the east, the other one also has an error that's too far to the east. So like you have to think about all the pairwise or co-variances. So you have to think about, you know, if you have 10 different sensors, you have, well, like 10 times nine different, you know, kind of relations there that you have to,
那么你最终就不会过度补偿。假设你的GPS和加速度计总是——我这是胡编的——但它们总是偏向东方。当一个有向东偏得太远的误差时，另一个也有一个向东偏得太远的误差。所以你必须考虑所有的成对或协方差。因此你必须考虑，如果你有10个不同的传感器，你就有大约10乘以9种不同的关系，你必须去
like, keep track of, you know, the common filter, you know, works off of those, you know, covariances that it accumulates over getting a lot of samples. And so it's going to take care of that for you. And so it's extremely powerful tool. Do we ever do a show on KF? I don't think we did. I don't know. I don't feel like it. It's always one of those things that it's always like just past my like feeling confident to talk about or use. You know what we should do? I know we both know who I'm talking about. There is a person who we should try and get on the show who we know who is amazing at this stuff. I'll give the really TLDR, but we should do a show on this. But there's something called a Gaussian process. And the idea is you have a bunch of inputs and you assume that
追踪它们。卡尔曼滤波器根据它在获得大量样本后累积的这些协方差来工作。因此它会为你处理好这些。所以它是一个极其强大的工具。我们有没有做过一期关于KF的节目？我觉得没有。我不知道。我感觉好像没有。这总是那种让我觉得稍微超出我自信讨论或使用范围的事情。你知道我们该做什么吗？我知道我们两个都在说谁。有一个人我们应该试着请到节目里来，我们认识他，而且他在这个领域超级厉害。我给个极简总结，但我们确实应该做一期关于这个的节目。但有一种东西叫高斯过程。其核心思想是你有许多输入，并且你假设
they're normally distributed or Gaussian distributed. And so that just means if there's going to be an error, it could just as easily be smaller or larger. That's the real hand wavy way of saying normally distributed. And so, you know, if all of your inputs are normally distributed and you have a process and the outputs of those process are like more linear distributed numbers, normally distributed numbers, then a Gaussian process will go through and like layer a bunch of functions to figure out like what composition of functions will get you from the inputs to the outputs. And so a common filter is like a specific type of Gaussian process where I believe the function is quadratic. I think you're making some assumptions there. It's basically, it makes some assumptions that take a really, really computationally difficult thing and make it
它们是正态分布或高斯分布的。这意味着如果有误差，它变小或变大的概率是一样的。这是一种用通俗易懂的方式来解释正态分布。所以，如果你的所有输入都是正态分布的，并且你有一个过程，这些过程的输出是更呈线性分布的数字、正态分布的数字，那么高斯过程就会遍历并叠加一堆函数，以弄清楚函数的什么组合能让你从输入到达输出。因此，卡尔曼滤波器就像是高斯过程的一种特定类型，我相信其中的函数是二次的。我觉得你在其中做了一些假设。基本上，它做了一些假设，把一个在计算上极其困难的问题变成
so that you could run it on a watch. That's basically, they figured out like, what are the assumptions that I need to make to run this thing, you know, in reasonable time. So like, if you have a ton of compute and not a lot of data, you know, a generic Gaussian process is really the best thing you can do, because it will like, it will explore all the possible functions and compositions of functions. But that's just not practical to do on, you know, on a reasonable device. And also like it, it, you can get really odd things that you're not expecting. And so a Kalman filter allows you to set really level expectations and on good compute. Well, we should do a whole show on it. But, but it's, it's an amazing achievement. So basically have one more
了你可以在手表上运行的东西。基本上，他们弄清楚了：为了在合理时间内运行这个东西，我需要做出什么假设？所以，如果你有大量的计算能力而没有多少数据，通用的高斯过程真的是你能做的最好的事情，因为它会探索所有可能的函数和函数组合。但在合理的设备上这样做并不切实际。而且它也可能会产生一些你意料之外的非常奇怪的东西。因此，卡尔曼滤波器允许你设定非常切合实际的期望，并且在良好的计算条件下运行。好吧，我们应该做一整期节目来聊这个。但是，这是一个了不起的成就。所以基本上还有
sort of like category of things to talk about just in this introduction, sort of like drop a bunch of terms and then and then run out the door. And that is like, when we talk about these things as well, we've been talking about right now, I'll describe as, and this means a lot of different things to a lot of different people, but real time, right? Like, I'm trying to decide right now, where I am. And as Jason mentioned, using computationally efficient mechanisms, because you want to do this, potentially on something that doesn't have infinite power. And so you're trying to figure out where you are right now you don't know where you're going to be a minute from now or a second from now you don't know any of that information and that's pretty
最后一类事情要在这次介绍中讨论，也就是抛出一堆术语然后拍拍屁股走人。那就是，当我们讨论这些事情时，我们刚才一直在谈论的东西，我会把它描述为——这对不同的人有许多不同的含义——实时，对吧？就像，我正试图立刻决定我在哪里。正如杰森所提到的，使用计算效率高的机制，因为你想在可能没有无限电力的设备上运行它。所以你试图弄清楚你现在在哪里，你不知道一分钟后或一秒钟后你会去哪里，你对所有这些信息一无所知，这与
different from if you say hey i have a recording of all this stuff like i went for a run and i get back this is not how they do it i'm just saying they could but if you go out for a run you collected all your sensor information and for instance you know you started and ended at your house well then I know for instance I can put a constraint that at the beginning and the end the two positions must be equal to each other because I went through my front door and so if you snap those two together then you can backwards like make offsets along the whole thing so that you sort of get a reasonable answer out. And you kind of call this like a batch, batch process. You batch up all the data and you process it at once. And at any point in time,
如果你说，嘿，我有所有这些东西的录音，就像我去跑步然后回来了——这不是他们的做法，我只是说他们可以这样做——但如果你去跑步，你收集了所有的传感器信息，例如，你知道你从家里出发并在家里结束，好吧，那么我就知道，例如我可以加上一个约束，即在开始和结束时，两个位置必须彼此相等，因为我是从前门出去的。所以如果你把这两点连起来，你就可以向后沿着整条路径进行偏移调整，这样你就能得到一个合理的结果。你把这叫做批处理过程。你把所有数据批处理起来，一次性处理。而在任何时间点，
you can look ahead and you can look back for certain milestones or things you're looking for. But what if you need to do something similar? Like what if you wanted to impose constraints, but while you're going in real time, like, hey, I'm running past a fountain and I ran past the fountain again. Like I knew that at the time, like I didn't need to wait till later to know that. And there are some techniques that use that because one thing we've not talked about is if you sort of watch any of the companies trying to do sort of robotic vehicles, if you look at little robots that move around interior spaces, they have need to kind of do do something. In addition to just figuring out where they are, they also need to figure out how to move around the space and how to understand that there's, you know, hey, I'm a little tank treaded robot that's going to serve Jason a very refreshing milkshake when he starts to get hungry because his auto GPT asked it to. And so the tank is in the other room, but it needs to know he left his sweater in a pile on the ground to avoid it, right? So it needs to understand where
你都可以向前看，也可以向后看某些里程碑或你正在寻找的东西。但如果你需要做类似的事情呢？比如你想施加约束，但又是在实时进行的时候，比如，嘿，我跑过了一个喷泉，我又跑过了那个喷泉。就像我当时就知道那样，我不需要等到以后才知道。有些技术就利用了这一点，因为我们没有讨论过的一点是，如果你观察任何试图制造机器人汽车的公司，如果你观察在室内空间移动的小型机器人，它们需要做一些事情。除了弄清楚它们在哪里之外，它们还需要弄清楚如何在空间中移动，以及如何理解，比如，嘿，我是一个履带式小机器人，当杰森开始饿了时，他（因为Auto GPT的要求）要给他送上一杯非常提神的奶昔。所以这个小坦克在另一个房间里，但它需要知道他把毛衣堆在地上的一堆里，以便避开它，对吧？所以它需要理解它在哪里，
it is, understand the world around it, how to maneuver. And it does this via a process called simultaneous localization and mapping, SLAM. You'll hear this referred to. And it uses some other things, but they all kind of fall in line with what we've already been talking about. So it can shoot beams of light out and measure distance using beam pulses of light to a wall or to the ground. It could use the same thing with ultrasonic sensors like a bat chirp. It chirps and then hears the response back. And it's getting all of these distances to objects, to the wall. It can use its camera to understand things.
理解它周围的世界，以及如何操纵。它通过一个叫做同时定位与建图（SLAM）的过程来做到这一点。你会听到这个词。它还使用其他一些东西，但它们都符合我们一直在讨论的内容。因此，它可以通过向墙壁或地面发射光束并利用光脉冲反射来测量距离。它也可以像蝙蝠的叫声一样使用超声波传感器。它发出尖叫声，然后听到回声。它正在获取到物体、墙壁的所有这些距离。它可以使用摄像头来理解事物。
And all of these become, what I said, these sort of constraints. So for instance, if it goes in a circle and comes back and sees the same spot it's been before, it knows those two things must be equal to each other in space, even if there had been some drift and it didn't initially think they were um and so you get these events that occur you input all these different measurements and you're at the same time building an understanding of the space where you are and where you are in that space there's some udacity courses that go over this and like some of their autonomous driving they have like a class about it
所有这些都变成了我所说的这些所谓的约束。例如，如果它绕了一个圈回来，看到了以前去过同一个地方，它就知道这两个点在空间中必须彼此相等，即使之前曾有过一些漂移，它最初并不认为它们是相等的。所以你会遇到这些事件，你输入所有这些不同的测量值，同时你也在建立对你所在的空间以及你在该空间中位置的理解。有些优达学城（Udacity）的课程会讲到这些，比如在他们的自动驾驶课程里，他们有一节专门的课
i'm pretty sure they are free or at least were free at some time because i watched them i think they're free yeah okay cool uh they have a whole discussion about a lot of these topics so if you want to go like next level deep they have stuff where they talk about common filters they talk about slam they have actually um i've seen it some data where they give you input and tell you you're a little robot and they talk about things we didn't talk about here, like particle filters, how to sort of understand multiple hypotheses about where you are. And as you're getting new input, how do you build a framework where you're incorporating it definitely would recommend checking that out. And it's pretty cool, because they have some data, you actually can
我确信它们是免费的，或者至少曾经是免费的，因为我看过它们。我觉得它们是免费的，对吧，酷。他们关于这些话题有很多讨论，所以如果你想深入了解，他们有讨论卡尔曼滤波器的内容，也有关于SLAM的内容。实际上，我见过一些他们提供输入的数据，告诉你你是一个小机器人，他们会讨论我们在这里没有讨论的事情，比如粒子滤波器，如何理解关于你身处何地多重假设。随着你获得新的输入，如何建立一个框架来整合这些内容？绝对推荐去看看。这挺酷的，因为他们有一些数据，你实际上可以
try to do this for yourself. And it's a simplistic thing without having to integrate a radar onto your milkshake delivering auto GPT. Yeah, no, slam is amazing. Again, it could be a whole show. But But, uh, you know, it's just fascinating. I think the way to think about it is, you sent out a little ray out of your camera, or it's passive. So it doesn't literally this way. But you've collected a ray of data, and it's red. And so you know that, like like if I was to shoot out a little ray that there would be a red thing there. But you don't know the depth, right? And so you say to yourself, well, somewhere on this ray is some red pigment. And then you turn a little bit and you look and you say, OK, now I have another ray.
自己尝试去做。这是一个简化的事情，无需将雷达集成到你的传送奶昔的Auto GPT中。是的，不，SLAM太神奇了。再说一次，这可以做成一期完整的节目。但是，你知道，这太迷人了。我认为思考它的方式是，你从你的摄像头射出一束小光线，或者它是被动的。所以它不是字面意义上这样射出的。但你收集了一束数据，它是红色的。所以你知道，比如如果我要射出一束小光线，那里会有一个红色的东西。但你不知道深度，对吧？所以你对自己说，在这束光线的某个地方有一些红色的色素。然后你稍微转过身去看，说，好吧，现在我有另一束光线了。
And if you have a lot of rays of red that all intersect, they say, oh, like this area in 3D, this is red. Maybe it's a part of a wall, a red wall or something. And so, yeah, all that stuff is just really fascinating and it runs at scale. It's just like a really, yeah, I would highly recommend checking out that. I've also checked out that Udacity course. I think you can basically take the course,
如果你有许多相交的红色光束，它们就会说，哦，3D空间中的这个区域是红色的。也许它是墙的一部分，红墙什么的。所以，是的，所有这些东西都非常迷人，而且它可以按规模运行。这就像一个真正的，是的，我强烈建议去看看那个。我也看过那个优达学城课程。我想你基本上可以学习这门课程，
but then if you want the certificate, then that costs a little extra, but you can audit the entire course. Really amazing stuff. I think, so now, you know, if you pull out your phone, if you go to, you know, Google Maps, Apple Maps, here, any of these map apps, you know, and you see the blue dot there, now you have an idea of all the work that's being done on your phone to put that dot in the right spot. It's really remarkable. And you also know, just one last recap, because a lot of people have asked me this, if you're downtown and the dot's bouncing all over the place, you also know why that is, because
但如果你想要证书，那就要多花一点钱，不过你可以旁听整门课程。真的很棒的东西。我想，现在，你知道，如果你掏出手机，如果你打开谷歌地图、苹果地图或者任何这些地图应用，你知道的，当你看到那个蓝色的点时，你现在就知道为把那个点放在正确位置而在你手机上所做的大量工作了。这真的很了不起。你也知道，做个最后的总结，因为很多人问过我这个问题，如果你在市中心，那个蓝点到处乱跳，你现在也知道为什么会这样，因为
the satellite energy is reflecting off those high-rise buildings. And now it says, it thinks you're further than you are. And so that it accidentally draws that sphere larger. And now it says it thinks you're, you know, further than you are. And so that it accidentally draws that sphere larger. And so now it's trying to reconcile that with all this other data. And so you kind of find yourself either bouncing around or it says you're going east, you're going north, like that's all because of that. This is a fun topic. This has been a good show. Yeah, this is great. you know send us uh some feedback if you do want to folks out there in the audience if you want us to cover slam or kfs or stuff you could definitely do that just let us know what y'all think it's great to get the feedback there
卫星能量正在从那些高层建筑上反射。现在它说，它认为你比实际位置更远。于是它不小心把那个球体画得更大了。现在它正试图将这一点与所有其他数据进行协调。所以你会发现自己要么到处乱跳，要么它说你在向东走、向北走，这一切都是因为这个。这是一个有趣的话题。这真是一档不错的节目。是的，这太棒了。你知道，给我们发送一些反馈，如果你想的话，听众朋友们，如果你想让我们报道SLAM或KF或类似的内容，你绝对可以做到，只需让我们知道你们大家的想法，收到反馈感觉太棒了。
was somebody who posted on patreon i don't know if patreon feeds are public or how this works but somebody posted saying you know they watched our show it uh gave them the tools they needed to get into some coding bootcamp. And now they're a C++ developer, which is amazing. Again, I don't know if the Patreon stuff is public, so I don't want to say your name, but that is amazing. If you're hearing this episode,
有人在Patreon上发帖——我不知道Patreon的信息流是否是公开的，或者这是怎么运作的——但有人发帖说，他们观看了我们的节目，这为他们提供了进入一些编程训练营所需的工具。现在他们是一名C++开发者，这太棒了。再说一次，我不知道Patreon的内容是否公开，所以我不想说出你的名字，但这太棒了。如果你听到了这一集，
major props to you. It definitely makes us feel good that we're able to help you out there, which is really cool. And yeah, definitely send us emails, post on Patreon. And it's always great hearing what folks have to say. Thank you, everyone.
给你大大的赞。这确实让我们觉得能够帮到你们感觉很好，真的很酷。是的，绝对给我们发邮件，在Patreon上发帖。听到大家的想法总是很棒的。谢谢大家。
Yep, see you later. Music by Eric Farndaler.ollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，再见。音乐由Eric Farndaler创作。编程抛弃秀（Programming Throwdown）在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0协议下发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，修改和调整作品，但您必须署名Patrick和我，并以相同方式共享。本集目前没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。